so da bin ich muss wieder bonbons lutschen wegen meinem hals teuer aber es
ist schon besser was nice liege gerade im kapp was ist
krank aus dass das kann ich hoffe es alles in ordnung
okay nein es wird nicht alles in ordnung sein weil sonst wärst du nicht im
krankenhaus liegst du da wegen wegen dem hier oder wegen was anderem auch
überhaupt man sound super catchy musik das ist aus dem diddy kong racing
n64 soundtrack
jetzt schon bett geben naja man kann es auch übertreiben 19 26
also 19 26 muss ich auch noch kein bett gemacht
aber bald ist schon spät oder auch nur war das beste offen war das beste ich
denke immer in der regel wenn jemand im krankenhaus ist dann ist es was
nicht
negativ ist was ist das gegenteil von volker jetzt hat man alles verstanden
glaube ich oder das ist bett die viele immer aus haben wir eigentlich bestimmt
überhaupt nicht was das anzeigt georgien am 23 nämlich vielleicht mit dem farb
ja ein video für weihnachten auf wenn er sich dazu durchringen kann
weil wir müssen jetzt ja alle erfahren warum der frasier jetzt tattoo foto model
in dresden ist was steht heute an ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich viel
doch ganz wichtig was mir gerade einfällt bis wann kann man bei amazon
bestellen
chip aller
aber warum warum muss ich bei chip gucken bis wann amazon liefert den schwachsinn
sie finden das lieferdatum auf der versandseite ach wirklich chip da werde
ich ja ohne euch nie drauf gekommen dass man auch die versamtseite gucken muss
dass man weiß was kommt ja übrigens geht amazon streiten oder
will streiken oder streiken gerade streikbar was von so bringt das nichts warum warum nicht
ich fände überhaupt nicht dass das wünschenswert wäre will dass mein zeug rechtzeitig ankommt das
meiste wozu das führt dass die leute wahrscheinlich auf dhl oder so angepisst sind die meisten haben
keine ahnung woran das liegt bei amazon was auch immer keine ahnung rail 7 ist raus hast du den
beitrag von shopify über deren black week ansturm gelesen und wusste gar nicht dass rails überhaupt
noch ja doch dass es entwickelt wurde wusste ich aber ich wusste nicht dass man neue version
rausgekommen ist ich war früher richtiger rubio rails fanboy ich habe aber jetzt schon jahrelang
nichts mehr damit gemacht aber ich denke ich käme immer noch halbwegs gut klar wobei da hat sich so
viel getan das letzte rails was ich wirklich viel benutzt hat war rails 3 also sagt schon alles war
das
2013 oder so ach du scheiße 2010 was das ist das ist ein web framework eigentlich somit das
bekannteste web framework seinerzeit ruby on rails war das ding was mit dazu geführt hat diese ganze
was weiß ich was war das web 2.0 diese ganzen hippen startup dinger die buchstaben weggelassen
haben im name
so wie twitter die dann aber nicht den buchstaben weggelassen haben oder oder was was gibt es ja noch
für die für komische dienste die die buchstaben weggelassen haben blicke gab es noch twitter
flickel es gibt ein wikipedia eintrag für pop champ ist ein emote used on streaming plattform
twitch da stellt euch mal vor da werden wir nicht drauf gekommen ohne wikipedia
used to show the streamer ich wusste gar nicht wie der typ heißt ryan gotex gut ja ja gut den haben
sie entfernt weil er irgendwelche weiß gar nicht was irgendwelche sachen glaube ich damals zu den sachen
usa gesagt hat irgendwas dazu irgendwelchen vorfällen ich glaube da wo sie dass das war nicht das weiße haus oder so was sie da gestürmt haben
hired by body
hk
Da hat er sich irgendwie zu geäußert auf Twitter und das hat dann keinem,
die Leute fanden das alle so schlimm und dann haben sie ihn entfernt.
Ich habe das nicht weiter verfolgt.
Der sieht mittlerweile auch ziemlich durch aus.
Ja, ich suche jetzt nicht danach.
Keck Welt, da hört man nach kurzer Zeit nicht zu.
Ja, also wer in Dresden wohnt, hat ihn vielleicht schon gesehen.
Angeblich, ich war in letzter Zeit nicht in Dresden,
aber angeblich ist der Friseur auf einigen Fotos,
sowohl auf Facebook, wohl auch irgendwie in Dresden selbst,
auf einigen Fotos von Tattoo Studios als Werbeträger.
Wie hören wir mal, das ist da genau nett in dem Fall zu sehen.
Ich sage euch, wie es ist.
Hätte der Fabian mal damals seinen Beauty-YouTube-Channel weitergemacht,
das wäre heute der erfolgreichste deutschsprachige männliche Beauty-YouTuber.
Der Typ sieht super aus dafür.
Der hat Ahnung von dem, was er macht.
Und das ist ja das, was die ganzen Beauty-Leute zum größten Teil nicht haben.
Wir haben ja keinen Plan.
Und der hat eine persönliche Persönlichkeit für sowas.
Aber gut, hatte keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist natürlich auch negativ.
Dann, wenn man nicht will.
Klar, kann man ja nicht erzwingen.
Läuft Shopify nicht größtenteils auf Rails?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich habe letztens ein Interview gelesen von interessieren Deutschen,
wenn ich mich jetzt nicht komplett vertue, mit dem, was ich gelesen habe.
Das ist ja ein Deutscher, der das gegründet hat.
Oder?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich habe letztens ein Interview gesehen mit dem Shopify-Gründer.
Das war ein Deutscher.
Ja.
Genau der.
Hast du dir mal die Matrix-Anil-Tech-Demo angeguckt?
Ja.
Und das Video.
Nicht bei mir lokal.
Sieht schon geil aus.
Natürlich.
Natürlich wird sowas nicht in Deutschland gegründet von einem Ausgewanderten.
Wir haben hier halt nicht so den richtigen Nährboten für solche Geschichten.
Was haben wir denn in Deutschland für große Software?
Dinger.
SAP?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch so?
Teamviewer.
Okay, das ist aber nicht in Regionen wie SAP.
Magenta Cloud.
Alles klar, Leute.
Wie sieht es eigentlich so im Magenta Gaming aus aktuell?
Ich mache mal kurz andere Musik.
Immer noch am Start.
Ach du.
Okay.
Es hat sich nichts geändert seitdem.
Außer SAP fällt mir da echt nicht mehr viel ein.
30 Terabyte die Minute.
Alter.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Das sind 43 Petabyte am Tag.
Das ist schon was.
Und bei uns machen die sich in die Hose, wenn sie 10.000 Requests am Tag kriegen oder in der Woche oder so.
Was?
Na gut.
Video Streaming mag mehr haben.
Aber bei einer Shopping Plattform, überlegt mal wie viele Sachen, bei einer Shopping Plattform dahinter laufen müssen, dass du auf 30 Terabyte die Minute kommst.
Ja.
Ist echt so.
Da ist Ruby on Rails tatsächlich mit dafür verantwortlich, dass das Web so ist, wie es heute ist.
Das war das erste, ich nenne es mal so, moderne Web Framework.
So das erste moderne Richtung, wie heißt das?
Das MVC, Model View Controller, was eben so richtig, so richtig Hype und Mainstream hatte.
Damals bei Ruby on Rails haben die Leute ja noch nach Rockstar Developern gesucht.
Das ist auch so eine ultra bescheuerte Bezeichnung.
Der Friseur sieht heute noch aus wie 25.
Ja, wir haben Crytek, aber Crytek spielt sicherlich nicht in derselben Liga wie SAP.
Und außerdem muss man sagen, Crytek hat ja leider die letzten Jahre...
Es ist jetzt besser geworden mit, mit Hunt Showdown, allerdings die Jahre dazwischen haben die ja auch nicht viel, ähm, nennenswertes hinbekommen, ne?
Ja gut, wir waren bei vielen Sachen mal ziemlich gut.
Ihr müsst euch mal das Foto, das Gruppenfoto angucken, ähm, wo Albert Einstein den Nobelpreis bekommen hat.
Warte mal.
Stein, Group, Foto.
Ja.
Alter, da sind sehr viele Deutsche drauf und von den Namen her kennst du gefühlt heute noch die Hälfte.
Also wir waren mal um diese Zeit richtig krass, was wissenschaftliche Sachen angeht.
Aber das mit Internet haben wir komplett verkackt.
Kennt ihr mal noch BTX?
Wurde damals von der Telekom als der neue Shit angepriesen.
Weiß nicht, ob das jemals, ob das jemals jemand gesehen hat.
BTX.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Videotext.
Das, ähm, war aber über Modem.
Oder ISDN damals.
Hätte, meint ihr wirklich?
Jetzt war immer, jetzt war eine Frage an euch, Chat.
Hätte 2000 rum jemand gesagt, analoges Telefon überlebt ISDN, hätte man die Leute ausgelacht.
Damals war ISDN der neueste Shit.
Heute denkt man sich, oh, zum Glück muss man kein ISDN mehr supporten.
ISDN kam zu spät.
ISDN war eine super Idee für Telefon.
Aber ISDN kam zu einer Zeit, oder wurde zu einer Zeit Mainstream, wo die Leute eigentlich schon aufs Internet geschielt haben.
Oh ja.
Dann ist ja alles gut.
Es gibt heute noch sehr viele Five Hats.
Allerdings habe ich den Eindruck, viele von denen sind ausgewandert.
Leider.
Oder haben keinen Bock.
Was dachte der sich immer noch?
Nein, da muss er aber ganz schön, das war ja abzusehen.
Moin, Sirius Max.
Leute, ich muss noch ein bisschen an meinem Bonbon lutschen, dass mein Hals wieder besser wird.
Lasst euch, lasst euch nicht.
Ich störe, sagt mir Bescheid, wenn es zu nervig ist.
Ich sacke sozusagen gerade.
Ach ja, Chat.
Muss euch ja noch was zeigen.
Es hat heute unter dem Video bei mir.
Hab ich das irgendwo auf?
Unter dem Video bei mir hat mich jemand gefragt, was ich zu der Stellenanzeige von, äh, von ihm, Schrägstrich, von dort, wo er die Webseiten betreut, von dem Unternehmen.
Was, äh, was, was ich dazu sage.
Und da habe ich ihm gesagt, ja, schickt mir das doch einfach mal den Link per Twitter.
Und das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Offene Stellen.
Warte mal, muss ich das mit, wenn ich das mit dem Darkreader aufhabe, sieht es dann an.
Ich hätte schon mal eine gute Webseite, die auch ohne Darkreader ordentlich aussieht.
Da bin ich schon mal, das ist schon mal Pluspunkt, Pluspunkt.
Also, was haben wir hier zur Auswahl?
Die Seite finde ich schon mal ganz schick.
Wir haben zur Auswahl Frontend-Entwickler, Backend-Entwickler oder Azubi.
Können wir auch mal aufmachen.
Gucken wir mal.
Frontend-Entwickler, gucken wir uns mal an.
Also, und ich habe ihm auf Twitter geschrieben, ich zeige das heute mal im Stream.
Und mein Stream kann da seinen Senf zu abgeben.
Also, sollte hier oben nicht der Name von der Firma stehen?
Also, es sind die Business Unicorns.
Das sind Stockbilder, oder?
Die kommen mir äußerst bekannt vor.
Ist das nicht, sind die Fotos nicht so ein super weit verbreiteter, ähm, Imagesatz?
Die sind, hast du, ach.
Da bist, die hast du selbst gemacht.
Okay.
Dann sieht es einfach nur vom Style so aus.
Was jetzt aber für die Stellenanzeige nicht wirklich relevant ist, ja.
Okay, also.
Ähm, kriegt man Zeug über die Firma erzählt.
So, der Job.
Es geht hier um Frontend-Entwickler.
Umsetzung komplexer Kundenanforderungen, Entwicklung von unkonventionellen Lösungen.
Ich finde, also mein, meine persönliche Meinung ist, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen wenig.
Ich meine, das kannst du ja zu mehr oder weniger jedem Job sagen.
Ist auch Kenntnis, er hat ja im LCSS modern.
Das moderne, das moderne JavaScript würde ich tatsächlich hinschreiben.
Du hast sicherlich noch welche, die kommen dann mit jQuery um die Ecke oder sowas.
Das finde ich gut.
Bei, äh, modernem Web-Framework würde ich vielleicht noch irgendwie was hinschreiben, was zum Beispiel, also im Prinzip das, was ihr verwendet.
Wäre schon mal ganz gut, wenn die Leute das können.
Technisches Verständnis von Digitalen, gutes Deutsch, Englisch.
Also es geht jetzt darum, Chat, ob ihr euch angesprochen fühlen würdet oder nicht.
Eigenverantwortliches Arbeiten und Mitdenken, okay.
Und, äh, das sind die Benefits.
Ich finde es insgesamt ein bisschen kurz.
Also ich denke, man könnte da durchaus, durchaus mehr schreiben, wenn ihr Benefits habt.
Also wenn ihr sowas habt, wie zum Beispiel, ich habe ja schon auf Twitter geschrieben, ähm, wenn ihr sowas habt, wie höhenverstellbare Schreibtische oder freie Betriebssystemauswahl.
Ich persönlich finde, ähm, freie Betriebssystemauswahl immer ein super Punkt, wenn, wenn es das gibt, wenn man das reinschreibt.
Also für mich ist das ein unglaublicher Pluspunkt, freie Betriebssystemauswahl.
Steht da doch?
Wo?
Ach da!
Ach ja!
Ups!
Das stand da schon die ganze Zeit da?
Ich habe das nicht gesehen, als ich vorhin reingeguckt habe.
Hardware und Dienstfahrrad-Leasing über Entgeltumwandlung.
Also ich finde es intern ist viel gut, Management.
Na doch, ist schon lesbar.
Ich habe es, ich habe einfach nicht richtig geguckt.
Also wie gesagt, ich finde es, ich finde es nicht schlecht, aber ich hätte, also keine Schmerzen, wenn da noch ein bisschen...
...genauer stehen würde, was denn so auf einen zukommt.
Weil das ist doch schon sehr allgemein.
Ich weiß nicht.
Chat, was sagt ihr?
Inwieweit würdet ihr euch angesprochen fühlen?
Was würdet ihr noch gerne haben wollen?
Gucken wir mal, Backend.
Benötigte Qualifikation.
Ja, das fände ich auch nicht schlecht, wenn das drin steht.
Umsetzung, Arbeiten mit APIs, Entwicklung von unkonventionellen Lösungen.
Gut, das ist auch mehr oder weniger für alles.
Das finde ich gut.
Das finde ich gut, dass das drin steht.
Shit plus Docker-Erfahrung.
Ja, auch nicht verkehrt.
Linux-Erfahrung.
Ja, das ist schon ein bisschen konkreter.
Ja, welches JavaScript-Framework würde ich auch reinschreiben?
Oder zumindest, was einem am liebsten ist.
Sieht nach Consulting aus?
Ja, gut.
Wenn es Consulting-Zeug ist, also sprich, wir verschachern, wir verschachern Leute an andere, an andere Unternehmen, dann ist das natürlich was anderes, ja.
Ja.
Ist es, glaube ich, nicht, oder?
Weiß ich nicht, was machen die denn?
Keine Ahnung.
Web of Tomorrow, Case Studies.
Nee, die entwickeln, die entwickeln Web-Anwendungen, oder?
Entwicklung, steht doch hier.
Ach so.
Beratung, ja, im Prinzip, im Prinzip.
Du kannst da deine Sachen, deinen Shop oder sowas entwickeln lassen.
Ja.
Ich bin da immer, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich bin da immer sehr unkreativ, was sowas angeht.
Also, ich könnte sowas.
Ich könnte sowas auch nicht schreiben.
Ich bin da immer relativ planlos.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich auf der Arbeit bei uns mal, bei einer Stellenanzeige, einen riesig langen Text an den jeweiligen Teamleiter geschrieben habe, warum ich das überhaupt nicht ansprechend finde.
Und bis heute hat sich daran nichts geändert.
Und die wundern sich immer noch, warum sie nichts finden.
Ich sage nicht, dass automatisch mit meiner Änderung die Leute Schlange stehen würden, oder sowas.
Aber sicherlich noch mehr.
Und da waren halt so Sachen drin, wie wir sollten hervorheben.
Wir sollten hervorheben, dass wir eine Kantine haben.
Wir sollten hervorheben, dass wir freie Betriebssystemauswahl haben.
Wir sollten hervorheben, dass wir höhenverstellbare Schreibtische haben.
Wir sollten hervorheben, dass wir ein Diensthandy bekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch mit flexible Arbeitszeit aussieht.
Also, Chat, wenn ihr noch irgendwas hinzuzufügen habt, schreibt es in den Chat.
Werden sich wahrscheinlich freuen.
So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Oh, Moment, ich muss mal kurz in den Chat gucken.
Das hat, nein!
Unsere Stellenanzeige ist so ziemlich, ich kann die euch jetzt nicht zeigen, weil...
Da müsste ich mich leaken, wo ich arbeite.
Das war mit die schlechtesten Stellenanzeigen, die man sich vorstellen kann.
Auf der anderen Seite stand bei uns total viel Schwachsinn drin.
So nach dem Motto, du sollst VMware können, du sollst Zappix können, du sollst Linux können, du sollst Active Directory können, du sollst Windows können.
So komplette sinnlose Dinger, die du eigentlich gar nicht brauchst im Support.
Das ging ja auch um die Support-Position auch noch.
Meinung zu.
Buy Thron.
Was ist das denn?
Secure your World.
Protect your Game from Cheating and Hacking.
Na, bestimmt AI-gestützte Anti-Cheat oder sowas.
Blockchain.
Blockchain AI Anti-Cheat.
Stonks.
Anti-Virtual Machine und Anti-Debugging Features.
Okay.
Da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Da habe ich zu wenig Plan von.
Um mich da qualifiziert zu äußern.
Was, das sind die ehemaligen Entwickler von EAC und Vanguard.
Okay.
Taugt das?
Ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Hallo, Max.
Sorry, hallo, Wobblors.
Ich bin fast mit dem Master fertig und im Master codet man nicht mehr wirklich viel.
In Stellenanzeigen steht aber immer gute Kenntnisse Java oder das schreckt mich immer etwas ab.
Naja, wie gut würdest du denn deine Kenntnisse in Java einschätzen?
Ich meine, nur weil man nicht mal tagtäglich größere Sachen programmiert, kann man ja trotzdem so weit den Durchblick haben, um wieder schnell reinzukommen.
Und mal davon abgesehen, man kann ja auch ohne Probleme so ein paar Übungsprojekte machen daheim.
Also wenn du jetzt nicht komplett planlos bist und da mal schon ganz gut drin warst, finde ich, spricht da eigentlich nichts dagegen.
Ich meine, solange du dich jetzt nicht irgendwie gerade als Senior Big Brain Lead Developer, was auch immer, bewirbst und dann sagst, ja, ich habe vor zwei Jahren zum letzten Mal drei Zeilen Hello World Java programmiert, dann ist das eigentlich kein Problem.
Würde ich so sehen.
Ob die Personalabteilung das auch so sieht, sei mal dahingestellt.
Was?
Freue mich gar nicht so viel.
Die VMs.
Die VM, die ich mit Abstand am häufigsten benutze, ist meine Deluxe VM.
Da immer einschalten.
Und bei der Gelegenheit, weil ihr seid Chat, ich mache die Qt-VM auch mal ab.
Auch mal an.
Hast du gesehen, dass Inscope Funnel wird?
Ja, habe ich vorhin gelesen.
Dann warum nicht?
Der ist auch bald irgendwann mal 30.
So in nicht mal allzu langer Zeit, glaube ich.
Wie erlisten der jetzt?
Der müsste auch so 28, 29, bald 30 oder so sein.
27?
Ja, ist doch ganz normales Alter.
So Chat, einmal für euch.
Bevor wir wieder ausmachen.
Okay, wir machen wieder aus.
Ja.
Also ich benutze die Deluxe VM eigentlich fast täglich mehrere Stunden.
Inscope hat genug Kohleunterhalt zu bezahlen.
Da mache ich mir keine Gedanken.
So ein Desktop, wenn der Chef vorbeikommt, wieso ist das Problem?
Das sieht wenigstens so aus, als würde man was arbeiten.
Außer Chat, ihr kennt das doch.
Sagt mir eine Sache und ich sage euch, wo sie ist auf dem Desktop.
Ist doch total easy.
Nur die Noobs haben irgendwelche Ordner und sortieren das dann irgendwo hin oder sowas.
Das ist doch...
So muss das sein.
Nein.
Da ist schon ein bisschen viel Schwachsinn drauf.
Ja, irgendwie so ein komisches Video, was wir mal zur Bewegungserkennung gebraucht haben.
Und so braucht keiner mehr.
Server 2.
Server 2 gibt es, glaube ich, nicht.
Ach doch, da oben.
Server 2.
So was nennt das Server, Alter.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Irgend so ein billiges Case.
Komplett auseinandergefrickelt.
Massive Server.
Wo ist der Poggers?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der auf dem Desktop überhaupt ist.
Ich glaube, der ist gar nicht auf dem Soft...
Ach doch, hier unten, da.
Wieso? Ich habe alles schnell gefunden.
Also, ich blicke da durch.
Außerdem.
Irgendwo muss der Kram doch hin.
Und warum sollte man den Desktop anders betrachten als jeden x-beliebigen anderen Ordner?
Oder habt ihr in jedem Ordner Unterordner und Unterordner und Unterordner?
Warum sollte der Desktop eine Sonderstellung haben bei Ordnern im Vergleich zu den normalen anderen Ordnern?
Genau, warum sollte man den Desktop als Desktop verwenden?
Wozu?
Was ist denn das hier?
Kann ich das angeben?
Ah.
Das ist die Firmware für das Thermometer.
Weiß ich wieder.
Da war in den letzten Daten was mit IT-Leitung.
Ne.
Das ist die Stellenanzeige, die wir heute im Video angeguckt haben.
Wieso hat man zweimal Firefox auf dem Desktop und LibreOffice?
Hat man auf dem Desktop, weil Firefox der Meinung ist, beim Updaten sich zweimal da platzieren zu müssen.
So.
Und LibreOffice hat man...
Hier.
Weil das ein Link ist, der beim Installieren schlicht und ergreifend angelegt wurde.
Und nachdem ich auf meinem Desktop nix mache, wie normale Leute auf ihrem Desktop, ist das ein ganz normaler Ordner und es juckt mich nicht.
Da geht's gut, die Licht gerade auf dem Schrank drüben, glaube ich.
Ist bei deinem Arbeits-PC auch so auf dem Desktop?
Weißt du, wie der Desktop von meinem Arbeits-PC aussieht?
So.
Genau so.
Mein Arbeits-PC hat nämlich keinen Desktop, wo man Icons drauf machen kann.
Hier läuft ein Prozess.
Hier läuft ein Browser.
Hier läuft ein Terminal.
Und hier läuft meistens irgendein Editor.
Das heißt, ich hab gar keinen Desktop, also gar keinen Anwendungszweck für Desktops, weil ich Anwendungen eigentlich nur im Fullscreen hab.
Ha, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ja, sie wollten mich auf der Arbeit zu Windows zwingen, aber nachdem mir noch keiner erklären konnte, wie ich dann gescheit arbeiten soll,
geschweige denn mir überhaupt ein Windows-Node-Pick zur Verfügung.
Dass man vielleicht sich das mal angucken kann, fällt das wohl auf kurze Sicht erst mal flach.
Ich hab die meisten Sachen bei mir in Linux.
Entweder Repo, Downloads oder tatsächlich direkt im Home liegen.
Ja, warum auch nicht, ne?
Ja, das ist der Wahnsinn bei uns.
Das ist eine gute Frage, dazu brauchen wir erst mal was, was wir basteln können.
Ich wollte mir ja Discord-Self-Haus zu Discord-Alternativen demnächst angucken.
Da gibt's ja ein paar.
Die wahrscheinlich alle nicht mal ansatzweise so gut sind wie das Original.
Ist auch im Schrank.
Die Katze ist auf dem Schrank.
Im Schlafzimmer, wahrscheinlich.
Gibt's keine Weihnachts-E-Modes?
Ach ja, stimmt, ich hab Anfang des Monats ja gesagt, ich mach Weihnachts-E-Modes rein.
Ich glaube, das lohnt sich jetzt auch nicht mehr, Weihnachts-E-Modes zu machen, oder?
Chat, was meint ihr, lohnt sich noch Weihnachts-E-Modes?
Doch.
Wenn ich das jetzt reinmach, ist es bis Ostern immer drin.
Sind immer noch drinne.
Ihr wisst genau, ich hab das das letzte Mal bis, keine Ahnung, Juni oder so drinne gehabt, die Weihnachts-E-Modes.
Wenn ich die jetzt reinmach, werden wir sie nicht mehr los.
Das ist egal.
Dann nächstes Jahr schreien die Leute wieder, Max, ich will endlich wieder normales Keckweh haben.
Übrigens heute, ne?
Unter dem Video, was ich heute hochgeladen hab.
Was da?
Da waren ja einige Leute ein wenig getriggert.
Weil ich mich über die christliche Stellenanzeige lustig gemacht hab.
Weiß gar nicht, warum die Leute bei so kleinen Sachen immer direkt vom Glauben abfallen, Alter.
Da muss man doch mal durch.
Oder?
Da kann man doch mal Augen zu und durch.
Ich mein, klar, man muss sich nicht drüber freuen.
Aber ich kann mir doch auch nicht alles zu Herzen nehmen, wenn eigentlich man...
Moment.
Die Beschreibung von meinem Video ist weg.
Okay.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass die wirklich...
Ich glaube nicht, dass die irgendjemand gelöscht hat, sondern dass das YouTube nicht richtig gespeichert hat.
Das Video hatte eigentlich schon eine Beschreibung in der ersten Zeile.
Da stand sinngemäß sowas wie, es wurde mal wieder Zeit für...
Oh, was hab ich geschrieben?
Es wurde mal wieder Zeit für Stellenanzeigen.
Und diesmal mit besonders weihnachtlichen...
Keine Ahnung, mit...
Was hab ich geschrieben?
Mit besonderlich weihnachtlichen...
Weihnachtlichem Touch oder sowas.
Aber ist es weg?
Okay.
Ich glaube aber, YouTube hat sie nicht richtig gespeichert.
Das backt einfach mal...
Das backt öfters mal rum.
Was ziemlich bescheuert ist.
Was mich gewundert hat in dem Video...
Es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die sagen, dass man Scrum Master und Projektleiter in einem sein kann.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das gehen soll.
Gottes Zorn.
Genau.
Bestimmt.
Ja, aber manche...
Manche...
Ähm...
Waren...
Weil es Grint ist.
Manche waren tatsächlich ein bisschen getriggert.
Und ich verstehe schon, weil man supergläubig ist, kann man sich darüber aufregen.
Aber das ist doch eigentlich die Luft nicht wert im Endeffekt.
Und am besten fand ich den, der mir erzählen wollte, dass sich Glauben und Wissenschaft nicht ausschließen.
Vor allem, wo ich von Naturwissenschaften gesprochen habe.
Und das stelle ich mir wirklich schwer vor.
Also ich stelle es mir wirklich schwer vor, gerade im Bereich, sagen wir mal irgendwie...
Ja, im naturwissenschaftlichen Bereich zu sein.
Und das zu wissen, was man eben heutzutage über unser Weltbild so weiß.
Und dann gleichermaßen gläubig zu sein.
Das stelle ich mir sehr schwierig vor, weil...
Dann musst du ja quasi an Dinge glauben, von denen du weißt, dass sie mit an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht so sind.
Das heißt, du musst dann eine Sache von beiden ausblenden.
Blende ich das Eigentliche aus, von dem ich normalerweise überzeugt sein müsste, dass es richtig ist?
Oder blende ich das aus, was ich glauben müsste?
Das ist einfach ein nicht überwindbarer Konflikt, der da entsteht.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie das zusammen funktionieren soll.
Das kann ich mir nicht erklären, wie das gehen soll.
Es gibt Leute, die biegen sich das immer zurecht.
Ist ja auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich habe ja da überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit.
Die sollen alle glauben und machen, was sie wollen.
Aber ich verstehe halt nicht, wie man das unter einen Hut bringen möchte.
Hast du smarte Lampen bei dir im Haus eingebaut?
Ja, ich habe einige.
Ich habe jetzt, wenn der Weihnachtsbaum an ist, habe ich...
Warte mal.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier LED-Streifen mit Controller.
Und eins, zwei, drei...
RGB-Lampen.
Und ein paar auf Reserve.
Ja, habe ich.
Was willst du wissen?
Ja, dann ist ja das nächste Problem.
Wo fängt es an und wo hört es auf?
Also wenn du anfängst, die Sachen nicht mehr wörtlich zu nehmen, die da drin stehen,
dann hast du, glaube ich, am Ende noch mehr Probleme, als du vorher eh schon hattest beim Erklären.
Also ich finde, das funktioniert bloß noch, wenn man komplett die aktuellen Erkenntnisse
oder das aktuelle Weltbild einfach ausblendet.
Aber wie gesagt, es soll ja jeder glauben.
Was er will, das ist ja jedem sein gutes Recht.
Aber ich verstehe halt nicht, wie man es unter einen Hut bringen kann.
Ja, da frage ich mich, wie das so jemand hinkriegt.
Sag mal, zumindest Informatik ist jetzt nicht zwangsläufig was in der Richtung,
wo ich sagen würde, es schließt sich prinzipiell aus.
Aber der interessiert sich ja dann sicherlich auch ein bisschen für...
von Mathe bis Physik.
Und spätestens...
Spätestens da ist es halt mit, wie soll ich sagen, an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeit so,
dass zum Beispiel die Welt nicht in sieben Tagen erschaffen wurde.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie man das unter einen Hut bringen will.
Das auf der einen Seite zu wissen und das dann aber nicht glauben zu können,
weil es nicht zueinander passt.
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wie die Leute das unter einen Hut kriegen.
Ich glaube, ganz ehrlich...
Jetzt habe ich das Wort verwendet.
Das Realistischste, was wir in dieser Richtung gesehen haben,
also das, was ja nicht realistisch ist,
aber das vielleicht noch am wahrscheinlichste,
ist das, was...
Ist das Scientology?
Oder wer ist das mit den Aliens, die uns irgendwann abholen?
Das ist ja von allen diesen Sachen noch in irgendeiner Art und Weise das Logischste.
Und das sagt schon was.
Wenn irgendwelche abgedrehten, durchgeknallten,
noch die beste Erklärung haben,
dann sollte man sich vor Gedanken drüber machen.
Wer ist denn das, dass die Aliens einen abholen?
Ich glaube, das ist nicht Scientology.
Irgendeiner glaubt, dass quasi, wenn die Welt untergeht,
uns die Aliens im Raumschiff abholen.
Und sind das die Zeugen Jehovas, die mit dem Alien-Raumschiff, oder?
Ich frage mich eh, wie die bestimmen wollen,
wer denn da jetzt reinkommt und wer nicht.
Naja, egal.
Zumindest das ist ja noch die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass wir hier irgendwann mal außerirdische landen.
Die Chancen sind nicht sonderlich groß,
aber wahrscheinlich größer, als dass die Welt in sieben Tagen erschaffen wurde.
Sind das geflashte Lampen, oder welche sind das?
Nein, das sind keine geflashten Lampen.
Das sind Livex, hab ich.
Livex RGB Lampen.
Und die LED-Streifen sind mit ESP32 Microcontroller.
Ja, die sind geflasht mit WLED.
Aber ich hab zum größten Teil so Dinger.
Alter, was ist mit euch los?
Normalerweise kostet es 40 Euro, oder so.
Sind die noch bei Sinn?
Ja, so, das sind die normalen Preise irgendwie dafür.
Null.
Ich glaub, es geht los.
Ja, ich find die Livex Dinger ganz okay.
Die sind wenigstens schön hell.
Nein, Philips Hue Lampen hab ich nicht.
Das halte ich für ein ziemlich teures und zu abgeschottetes Ökosystem.
Und ja, ich weiß, man kann die Dinger mittlerweile integrieren.
Aber es kommt öfters mal vor, dass Philips Hue mit, ähm,
also, wie berühmt, berüchtigt dafür, mit Firmware-Updates irgendwelche Funktionen abschaltet, und sowas.
Das muss nicht sein.
Sicherlich ist das alles so eine Interpretationsfrage.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn man anfängt, davon abzuweichen, was da steht.
Also, wenn man sagt, hey, das, was in der Bibel steht, oder in irgendwelchen, was in irgendwelchen heiligen Schriften steht,
wenn man davon abweicht und sagt, ah,
ja, das darf man nicht so wortwörtlich nehmen,
dann ist die erste Frage, die sich einem aufdrängt, ist,
warum lügen einen die Schreiber an, wenn sie es doch besser wissen?
Zweitens ist, wer definiert, ab wann man was wörtlich nimmt, was da drinsteht, und ab wann nicht?
Und wer hat so die Deutungshoheit darüber?
Es gibt zum Beispiel im Nahen Osten sicherlich nicht wenige, die der Meinung sind,
dass man den Koran wörtlich nimmt.
Und auch in den USA haben wir letztens ein Video gesehen.
In den USA gibt es Leute, die sagen, die Bibel muss wörtlich genommen werden.
Und Noahs Flut hat den Grand Canyon in unter einer Woche erschaffen.
Gibt es Leute, die behaupten das, weil das so in der Bibel steht?
Das ist halt, sobald du anfängst, davon abzuweichen, hast du noch größere Erklärungsnöte, als du ohnehin schon hast.
Deswegen verstehe ich nicht, wie man das, das, das kriegt man nicht,
das kriegt man nicht unter einen Hut.
Was hältst du von Wordpress?
An sich nicht schlecht.
Wordpress ist ja berühmt, berüchtigt.
Gucken wir mal.
Gibt sich irgendwo eine schöne Übersichtsseite, was so in Wordpress 2021 war?
Wieso wenig?
Wie?
Das ist alles?
Das ist aber viel zu wenig für Wordpress.
Die hatten nur acht Sicherheitslücken im Jahr.
Wordpress ist doch berühmt, berüchtigt dafür, dass es löchrig ist wie so ein Schweizer Käse.
Aber gut, immerhin einmal Code Execution.
Ja, die Plugins, das kommt noch dabei.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie schlimm es ist mittlerweile.
Ich habe Wordpress schon seit Jahren nicht mehr selbst verwendet.
Geschweige also, selbst verwenden habe ich es noch nie, aber auch nicht mal administrieren müssen.
Was?
Wordpress, habe ich das Falsche?
Okay, zeig mal her.
Ja gut.
Und was sind 2021?
Davon?
Achso, 2021, lull.
Oh ja.
Das ist ja ein bisschen was.
Wie viel sind denn das? Kann man das zählen lassen?
Wenn nicht zählen, wenn das...
Wenn nicht, wenn nicht lassen...
Oh Mist.
Wenn nicht, lassen wir das jetzt mal zählen schnell.
Wie viel sind denn das?
Lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz Wim...
Wim Magic machen.
Wobei, eigentlich brauche ich...
Ups.
Uiuiuiui.
Ich habe, ich habe mal...
Set Paste.
So.
Was ist hier?
Save S.
Wordpress.
Keg W.
WC-L.
Wordpress.
913 Sicherheitslücken in 2021.
Ja, das ist eher mein Wordpress, so wie ich es kenne.
Ja.
Das bewegt sich...
913.
Das bewegt sich eher in dem...
In der Größenordnung, wie ich mir das vorgestellt hätte.
Ich glaube daran, dass C++ eine gute Sprache ist.
Siehste?
Das ist wieder ein schönes Beispiel.
Daran muss man nicht glauben.
Wir wissen mittlerweile, dass C++ Kacke ist.
Keinerlei Raum für irgendwelche Glaubensspekulationen.
Ich habe...
Ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
Ich habe einen...
Einen C++ Con Vortrag gesehen.
Okay.
Wo ich mir wieder gedacht habe, was zum Teufel ist mit C++ los?
Glaubt das da?
So.
Allein schon, wenn man den Titel liest und an solche Dinger da sieht...
Nee, das war der Vortrag nicht.
Das war das...
War das nicht.
War was anderes.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest habe ich wieder gefragt, was zum Teufel macht das C++ Gremium da?
Und ein weiterer Nachteil bei C++ ist ja, selbst wenn das Gremium mal einen neuen Standard
verabschiedet, bis der jemals, wenn überhaupt, in allen Compilern und Plattformen drauf ist,
vergehen eh 100 Jahre.
Weiß nicht, ob wir es sehen werden...
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir es erleben werden, dass in nächster Zeit, dass alle C++20 Features
implementiert sind, sowohl in GCC, als auch in der Visual Studio Geschichte und sonst
Dingen.
Im Leben nicht.
Die haben dann immer irgendwelche Eigenheiten davon noch.
Das ist grausam.
Captain Peng eingeschüffelt 14 Monate Subscription.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Die Sache ist nur die, wenn das in Konflikt gerät.
Also stell dir mal vor, du bist Naturwissenschaftler und du weißt mit an Sicherheit grenzender
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Welt nicht in sieben Tagen erschaffen wurde.
Was machst du dann?
Glaubst du das dann trotzdem?
Oder nicht?
Wo fängt es an und wo hört es auf?
Das stelle ich mir als unglaublich schwierig vor.
Deswegen bin ich auch davon ausgegangen, dass in technischen Berufen und gerade auch in
Naturwissenschaften Religiösität nicht so verbreitet ist, weil ich nicht mir vorstellen
kann, wie die Leute das unter eine Haube bringen wollen.
D++ ist gut, wenn man sich ins Jahr 2000 zurückversetzt.
Vielleicht.
Wobei man da auch hätte passé bleiben können.
Das ist zwar manche Sachen umständlicher, aber wenigstens klarer.
Ja gut, du kannst ja auch deine eigene Religion zurecht machen.
Wie das beispielsweise die, wie gesagt, ich glaube die Zeugen Jehovas sind es, die was
man von Alien-Raumschiffen erzählen.
Klar, du kannst dir immer was Eigenes überlegen, was der Sache da nicht widerspricht.
Fünf Jahre später gibt es neue Erkenntnisse.
Und dann ist es wieder was anderes.
Dann ist es wieder was, was nicht passt.
Das funktioniert einfach nicht.
Das ist dann halt immer schwierig.
Ich kenne das.
Ich kenne meine Mutter ist auch wirklich großartig, gläubig, aber schon in die Richtung.
Die erzählt auch immer so Sachen.
Und wenn man dann fragt Okay, wo fängt es denn an und wo hört das auf?
Ja, man weiß man ja nicht so genau.
Heute ist das nicht ausgebaut.
Die Schraube im Gehäuse verloren.
PC einschalten.
Boom Netzteil kaputt.
Keckweh.
Nee, nicht Keckweh.
Ich würde eher sagen Monka Smoke.
Oder gut.
Ich meine, für uns Keckweh, für dich vielleicht nicht.
Jetzt weiß ich, wo die alte, wo, wo ich kann sagen, wo die alte weiß ich, wie ich auf
alte gekommen, wo die Schraube geblieben ist.
Ja, im Netzteil wahrscheinlich.
Oder war das Scientology mit den mit den Aliens?
Ich kann.
Es gibt irgendeine Glaubensgemeinschaft.
Die ist der Meinung, wenn die Welt untergeht, kommen die Aliens und nehmen uns im Raumschiff
mit.
Könnte durchaus Scientology sein.
Könnten auch die Zeugen Jehovas sein.
Sonst was.
Man muss ja mir ehrlich sagen, vom Ansatz her ist es alles Schwachsinn.
Das nimmt sich ja nix.
Das, was sich was nimmt, ist, was die ganzen.
Ja, Vereine da oder Gemeinschaften daraus machen unterm Strich.
Das die Mormonen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Letztendlich ist es auch egal.
Es gibt welche und das ist schon merkwürdig genug.
Guckst du Dart WM?
Nee.
Spielt da Marcel Scorpion mit?
Mittlerweile?
Nein, wahrscheinlich spielt er da nicht mit, aber ich weiß, dass der sich voll für Dart
interessiert hat.
Mal vor der Weile.
Gibt's den überhaupt noch auf YouTube?
Moment.
YouTube.
Marcel Scorpion Prostitution.
Wo ist er denn?
Gibt's den noch?
Wie?
Den gibt's nicht mehr.
Wo?
Wo ist er denn hin?
Darts hier.
Ah ja, hier ist er noch am Start.
Okay.
Ah, Reaction Videos.
Nice.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Darts.
Bam.
Ich fasse es nicht, Reaction Videos.
Reaction Videos gehen immer.
Angebot und Nachfrage.
Ey, ich darf nichts sagen, ich habe auch letztens ein Reaction Video hochgeladen.
Hast du schon mal Udemy Kurse gemacht?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es ein Udemy Kurs war.
Aber es könnte sein.
Ich habe mir damals einen EmberJS Kurs gekauft, als man noch nichts von React und Vue bei Frontend
Frameworks wusste.
Und ich sage euch, EmberJS ist der komplizierteste Upfuck aller Zeiten.
Ich habe damit nie wirklich was gemacht, über Basics hinaus, weil es so unglaublich unintuitiv
war.
3D Drucker gepimpt.
Ist das ein i3 Mega?
Sieht vom Display ähnlich aus.
Und heißt, du hast dir selbst so einen eigenen Lüftergehäuse gedruckt dafür.
Ja, wie gesagt, das kann ja jeder machen, was er will.
Ist ja sein gutes Recht.
Aber nachvollziehen muss ich das ja dann nicht.
Aus Singapur.
Inwiefern?
Was kam denn bei euch an?
HTTP Requests oder was?
Mit irgendwie Log4j Geschichten im Payload oder was?
Port 80.
Ja, dass die China-Chinesen da schon abgehen in der Richtung, das war ja klar.
C plus?
Ja, das fehlt noch.
Holy C gibt es noch.
Ja, das funktioniert aber auch nicht so wirklich, weil der Erkenntnishorizont verschiebt sich
ja immer.
Und das hast du gesehen.
Dort, wo man noch vor 100 Jahren fest dran geklebt hat, da hat man noch ein bisschen
mehr rausgestellt.
Also, naja, mittlerweile kann man das erklären und es ergibt nicht viel Sinn, woran man geklaut
hat.
Glaubst du, Rust wird sich gegen C++ durchsetzen?
Nein.
Also, kommt drauf an, in welchem Bereich.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Rust jemals C++ ablösen wird, weil gerade im Gaming-Bereich, gerade
wenn man sich Unreal anguckt, ist halt C++ das Ding schlechthin.
Ja.
Es gibt auch viele große Projekte wie Qt für Guis und sowas in C++, die wird es nicht
alles neu in Rust geben.
Aber im Embedded-Bereich fände ich das persönlich ganz nice, wenn Rust, also ich fände es zum
Beispiel cool, könnte ich mein ESP32 mit Rust programmieren anstatt mit C++.
Rust ist halt auch ein bisschen abfuck, weil Rust eben sehr pingelig ist, was Compiler-Sachen
angeht.
Dafür funktioniert in der Regel dein Scheiß, man kann nicht sagen fehlerfrei, weil du kannst
ja immer noch Logikfehler haben, aber zumindest funktioniert in Rust der Kram so, wie er da
steht.
Meistens.
Wenn du ihn dann ausführst.
Wenn natürlich ein Logikfehler drin ist, nicht.
Aber es macht das, was da steht.
Das ist bei C++ nicht zwangsläufig so.
NexoStyver, danke für den Sub.
Wie kamst du zu deinem Twitch-Nickname?
Ähm, das war irgendwas random, spontanes.
Ja.
Und ich habe den Twitch-Account erstellt, bevor ich streamen wollte.
Ich war damit schon lange auf, Jahre auf Twitch unterwegs.
Und ich habe ziemlich blöde Sachen auf Twitch geschrieben, also falls mal einer nach den,
falls es irgendwelche Chatlogs gibt oder so, keine Ahnung.
Also nichts Anstößiges oder so, halt dummes Twitch-Gespamme.
Das würde ich heute mit dem Account nicht mehr machen.
Das kann ich verstehen, gerade wenn man einen Server im Internet stehen hat.
Bisschen Paranoia ist aber auch nicht verkehrt.
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe beispielsweise total oft den Prozessexplorer im Hintergrund laufen.
Dass ich mitbekomme, was bei mir auf dem Rechner so los ist.
Ist zwar Schwachsinn, es sei denn der Chat ist wieder heute richtig Hackerman unterwegs.
Und hackt meinen Chat über, über, hackt meinen Rechner über den Twitch-Chat.
Ähm, aber ansonsten ist...
Ist zwar Schwachsinn, aber ich weiß trotzdem gerne, was im Hintergrund läuft und was abgeht.
Kann ich, kann ich komplett nachvollziehen.
Idee zu was? 3D-Drucker, was?
Achso, hier, dazu.
Ähm, nö.
Bisschen Paranoia ist nicht verkehrt.
Ich mein, du kannst dir im Zweifelsfall natürlich ein bisschen Monitoring einrichten.
Was guckt, äh, angemeldete User, CPU-Auslastung und sowas in der Richtung.
Ne, das Problem ist, Rust ist in sich schlüssig, C++ nicht.
Was benutzt du eigentlich für eine Tastatur? Bin gerade auf der Suche nach einer fürs Tippen.
Im Homeoffice mal ein bisschen zu zocken hab ich...
Also ich hab aktuell hier eine Logitech, äh...
Ist ne gute Frage, was das für eine ist.
Chat, ihr wisst wahrscheinlich besser als ich, was ist denn das für eine Tastatur?
Logitech G512.
G512.
Die ist aber nicht gut, weil die erste hab ich schon verschlissen.
Da ist die Control-Taste einfach abgebrochen.
Warum ich die habe, liegt daran, weil ich die Makro-Software von Logitech mag.
Auf der Arbeit hab ich das hier.
Auf der Arbeit hab ich eine Ducky One Skyline.
Allerdings, die Variante hier, mit NumBlock.
Sieht genauso aus wie da auf dem Bild.
Könntest du dir vorstellen, selbst mal eine Tastatur zusammen zu bauen?
Ja, könnte ich, aber ich wüsste nicht warum.
Der Felix bei mir von der Arbeit, der hat sich letztens eine Tastatur selbst zusammengebaut.
Hat mir auch ein paar Fragen gestellt.
Hat mir auch ein paar Fotos von gepostet.
So eine Mini-Tastatur ist das.
Das ist quasi nur dieser Teil hier, irgendwie von einer Tastatur.
So ganz merkwürdig, so ein richtig kleines Mini-Teil.
Natürlich mit RGB und sonst was, was er sich da gebaut hat.
An sich eine coole Geschichte, aber es kann sein, dass es das ist, tatsächlich.
Möglich.
Möglich, dass sowas in der Richtung ist, ja.
Sowas, ja.
Aber ich habe den Sinn für mich da drin nicht gesehen, ehrlich gesagt.
60% Keyboard.
Keine Ahnung, ich habe den Sinn nicht erkannt für mich da drin.
Also die zwei Sachen kann ich halt aus erster Hand berichten.
Also wie gesagt, einmal die G512 Logitech.
Die habe ich hier daheim.
Davor hatte ich eine Corsair, die war richtig räudig beschissen.
Sag ich so wie es ist.
Corsair K95 oder sowas war das.
Das war richtiger Müll.
So mit doppelten Tastenanschlägen und sowas.
Ganz, ganz großer Mist.
Und auf der Arbeit habe ich die.
Was, das Belle Delphine Keyboard.
Ach ja, endlich.
Ja, da haben wir alle drauf gewartet.
Leute.
Da haben wir ja drauf gewartet hier.
Das Belle Delphine Keyboard.
Endlich.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, was ich mir für eine Tastatur kaufe danach.
Die Belle Delphine Combo.
Moment, warum kostet das monatlich?
Warum kostet das monatlich?
Warum im Alles in der Welt kostet das monatlich?
Warum muss ich für das Belle Delphine monatlich bezahlen?
Raten.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ich traue mich nicht.
Leute, ich traue mich nicht weiter runter zu scrollen.
Ich traue mich nicht weiter runter zu scrollen auf der Seite.
Toss.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ich sag euch Leute, bald brauchen wir gar keine Tastatur mehr.
Dann benutzen wir alle Keyboard as a Service.
Wie auch immer das funktionieren soll, irgendeiner wird es schon erfinden.
Bestes Emote hier.
Gachi Roll.
Ich habe das Emote letztens auf dem anderen Channel gesehen.
Hat mir gedacht, das brauche ich.
Gachi roll.
Slash Exploit klingt ziemlich nach China-Chinesen-Hacker.
Wir bräuchten es.
Ja.
Wir bräuchten eigentlich noch eine China-Variante davon.
Können wir da nicht einfach irgendwie so eine rote Fahne drüber machen oder so?
So eine rote Fahne overlayen.
Das ist dann der China-Hackerman.
Und rote Fahne funktioniert gleichermaßen auch.
Da haben wir zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe geschlagen.
Das funktioniert auch für den Gecommoded-Hackerman.
Wir müssen das einfach nur rot machen.
Das können sowohl die Chinesen als auch die Russen dann sein.
Da haben wir zwei 2-in-1-Hackermen.
Und die normalen Matrix-Hackermen haben wir ja auch noch.
Was? Du würdest den Raspberry Pi austauschen.
Für was? Habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
Ach hier.
Bei meinem alten Raspberry Pi 1 färbt sich die Platine gelblich.
Nö, das ist nicht schlimm in der Regel.
In Raucherhausen.
In Raucherhaushalten war das früher noch viel schlimmer.
Das ist meistens nichts Schlimmes.
Du kannst es theoretisch wahrscheinlich sogar mit ein bisschen Alkohol oder so sauber machen, wenn du willst.
Aber wozu?
Alternativ kannst du einfach die SD-Karte rausnehmen und den neuen...
Wobei, Moment, Moment.
Raspberry Pi 1, ist der Raspberry Pi 1 nicht noch am V6?
Beides ist egal.
Die neuen Kernels sind da ja auch drauf.
Okay, dann wird die neuen...
Würde ich trotzdem vielleicht mal neu installieren.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass du dir da Gedanken machen musst.
Doomswap, dankeschön für den Sub.
Weiß nicht.
Ja, wie gesagt, die habe ich auf der Arbeit seit...
Weiß nicht, zwei oder drei Jahren.
Also ich hatte die schon eine ganze Weile vor Corona.
Das heißt, müssen jetzt ja eigentlich zwei Jahre sein.
Mindestens. Eher drei.
Und rein zum Arbeiten ist die gut.
Ich kann dir noch einen Tipp zugeben zu dieser Tastatur.
Ähm.
Die ist mechanisch und relativ laut.
Und wenn du die auf der Arbeit verwendest, dann könnte das sein, dass Kollegen von dir abgefuckt sind.
Ich habe mir da für die Tasten, wo ich neige...
Ihr wisst ja, ich neige zum Beispiel extrem, den NumBlock Enter zu hauen und sowas in der Richtung.
Und auch linkes...
Linker Control-Knopf und sowas ist auch was, wo ich gerne drauf haue.
Ich habe da so Silikonringe unter speziellen Tasten, dass es nicht so sehr bumst.
Kann ich empfehlen.
Nicht überall drunter.
Das macht ja den Sinn von einer mechanischen Tastatur.
Schon wieder irgendwie ein bisschen stellt das in Frage.
Aber unter manche Tasten, wo man dazu neigt, besonders fest drauf zu hauen, finde ich das nicht verkehrt.
Stimmt.
Leute, die 5G-Antenne haben wir schon im Arm.
Weiß nicht, ob mich eine Enter-Taste so als Rage-Kissen irgendwie...
Nee.
Dann würde ich mir lieber ein Anime-Bodypillow...
...vorkaufen.
Alter!
Das ist aber jetzt schon wirklich grenzwertig hier.
Was es da bei Amazon gibt, Alter.
Jetzt wird es aber langsam sehr grenzwertig.
Toss.
Ja, wenn das bei Amazon drauf ist, da ist ja nichts Toss.
Aber es geht schon auf jeden Fall in die Toss-Richtung, ja.
Ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass man da bei Amazon nicht danach suchen kann.
Tja, hätte ich jetzt nicht mit gerechnet.
So.
Ja, Leute, wir gucken jetzt nochmal ein bisschen auf YouTube.
Was haben wir denn hier so?
Ihr seid euren Lieblingsentwicklern egal.
Gewöhnt euch dran.
Wenn Maurice das sagt, da hat er wahrscheinlich recht.
Maurice hat oftmals recht in seinen Videos.
Und was ich cool finde, wahrscheinlich ist auch der Grund, warum ich die Videos von Maurice ganz gerne gucke.
Meistens geht das, was ich eh schon denke und das, was er sagt, in eine ähnliche Richtung.
Deswegen, es ist ja oft so, dass man sich Leute sucht, die ähnliche Sachen zu dem erzählen, was man eh schon quasi denkt.
Und das guckt man dann gerne.
Ach, guck mal, Levelcare.
Ach, guck mal, das ist ein schlecht bewertetes Levelcap-Video.
Es gibt jetzt zwei Sachen, warum das schlecht bewertet sein kann.
Entweder, weil die Fanboys angepisst sind, dass er die Wahrheit sagt über das Spiel.
Oder, weil die Leute angepisst sind, dass er es zu positiv beschreibt.
Aber elf Minuten können wir uns mal angucken.
Wahrscheinlich ist es aber typisches Levelcap-G-Baiten.
Der redet wahrscheinlich einfach zwölf Minuten im Kreis.
Und ich gebe ihm mal zwei, drei Minuten die Chance.
Aber wenn er sich dann zwei, drei Minuten nur im Kreis redet, dann wird das nichts.
Levelcap streamt.
Wisst ihr, was ich interessant finde?
Ah, okay.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Levelcap hat weniger Zuschauer als ich auf Twitch gehabt beim Battlefield-Streamen.
Das kann ja nicht sein.
Wobei, das ist auch der Beweis dafür, dass YouTube einfach eine Kack-Streaming-Plattform ist.
Lol, du siehst noch Dislikes.
Es gibt zwei Varianten.
Entweder haben die die Dislikes progressiv jetzt deaktiviert, dass es nicht überall ist, weil ich weiß, sie wollten das eigentlich machen.
Nee, nee, nee, das Plugin kann das auch nicht überall herziehen.
Oder, für dieses Video gibt es noch welche.
Sie haben sich Dislikes im Vorfeld von dem Video gespeichert, was ja nicht sein kann, das ist vom 20. Dezember.
Oder, das hier ist irgendeine errechnetes Dislike-Verhältnis.
Wobei ich das an der Stelle...
...gar nicht mal glaube.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, was Levelcap zu sagen hat.
Die Dislike-API sollte, glaube ich, am 12. oder so schon abgeschaltet werden.
Kann aber auch sein, dass ich mich vertue da jetzt.
Moin.
Nein, ja.
Manche Sachen...
...die einfach nur komplett broken waren, sind jetzt ein wenig weniger broken.
Aber massively improved ist vielleicht dann etwas zu viel des Guten.
...die Dinge nicht so viel.
DICE hat ihren Live-Service-Kontent-Rollout gestartet, der bis jetzt dezent Weapon-Skins und neue temporäre Game-Modes beinhaltet.
Es gab überhaupt nichts Erwähnenswertes, außer vielleicht ihre Rush-Geschichte.
Egal, egal, ich lasse ihn jetzt mal reden.
Und generell gesagt, wenn man sich auf Reddit anschaut, scheint das Gemeinschafts-Sentiment am Game meist negativ zu sein.
Obwohl die Leute, mit denen ich eigentlich spreche, die das Game spielen, es am meisten genießen.
Und das bedeutet...
Das liegt doch daran, Leute, die das Spiel jetzt spielen,
hat ja einen Grund, warum die das spielen.
Wenn sie das nicht zumindest ein bisschen enjoyen würden, würden sie nicht spielen.
...dass es schwierig ist, eine Lesung des Spiels zu bekommen, da so viele Leute das Spiel deutlich nicht mögen.
...dass es schwierig ist, eine Lesung des Spiels zu bekommen, da so viele Leute deutlich nicht mögen.
Es ist überhaupt nicht hart, deinen Read rauszubekommen.
95% ist einfach negativ.
Und ja auch nicht einfach nur irgendwie auf Gefühlsbasis oder so.
Du kannst ja auch die Punkte ganz klar benennen, wie das DICE zum Beispiel sagt, Scoreboards sind ein Legacy-Feature.
Das hat ja noch nichts mit Gefühl zu tun, das ist ja Fakt.
Was ich sagen kann ist, dass es schuldig ist.
So far, DICE has patched the game faster than I have seen them patch any other Battlefield game in my past 10 years of covering the franchise.
Das heißt ja nix.
And that's not to say that all the bugs and performance problems have been solved, but to me...
Das heißt ja insofern nix. Die anderen Games waren zwar auch kaputt, aber keines war so extrem borderline vom Designer im Arsch und borderline unplayable wie Battlefield 2042.
Selbst Battlefield 4 nicht.
This does speak well about DICE's commitment to the future of the game.
So far, and this again is speaking from my personal experience, but they fixed basically all of the connectivity issues with getting onto servers, a lot of the performance and lags, stuttering issues with servers.
Okay, sie haben gefixt, dass du das Spiel jetzt spielen kannst. Ja, gut Job.
They fixed and or balanced most of the weapons impressively fast and they fixed some of the UI quality of life issues, though there's still some work to be done there.
And they've also updated the breakthrough maps that had borderline impassable objectives.
Das stimmt.
And now the objectives are in new locations.
Now all that.
Besser sind sie trotzdem nicht.
They said Dataminer Temporial's latest datamine seems to indicate that we may not get DICE's first season of content until...
Das hat Tom Henderson auch geleakt, das kann ich mir auch durchaus vorstellen, da muss ich das mal überlegen.
Die bringen ein Spiel im November raus in einem absolut desaströsen, desolaten Zustand, haben eigentlich nix zu bieten und wollen die nächste Season, wo dann auch nicht viel kommt, muss man ja dazu sagen, da kommt irgendwie eine Map und ein...
Ich weiß nicht mehr, ob ein Specialist kommt, es kommt eine Map und ein paar Waffen oder so.
Äh, im März starten.
What the fuck?
Bis dahin ist das Spiel tot, ja?
Klar.
Es spielt ja jetzt schon keiner.
Die Spielerzahlen die letzten zwei, drei Tage waren deutlich besser, weil Free Weekend ist.
Aber selbst Free Weekend kann da nicht drüber hinwegtäuschen.
Gucken wir doch mal.
Steam.
Ja.
Da ist nix hängen geblieben großartig vom Free Weekend.
Nahezu nichts.
Okay, wir waren schon mal runter auf 10.000.
Letztens waren wir runter auf 16.000.
Okay, okay.
Man muss sagen, das sind nicht die absoluten Spielerzahlen, da fehlt Origin und die Konsolen natürlich, aber der Trend ist ja das, um den es geht.
Ja, das ist nix.
Das ist nix.
Ich mein, ich hab nie großartig Fortnite gespielt, aber ihr erinnert euch doch bestimmt noch an dieses Event mit dem schwarzen Loch und sowas.
Die haben das richtig gut gemacht bei Epic Games und Fortnite.
Du warst permanent begeistert, dieses Spiel zu spielen.
Es kamen permanent Dinger, die die Leute eben gehypt haben, permanent neu.
Die haben das richtig gut gemacht.
Das muss man auch mal sehen.
Und da kann man auch nicht die Augen davor verschließen.
Man hat gesehen, dass das erfolgreich funktionieren kann.
Aber da muss halt auch der Content dazu passen.
Und die Leute wissen, was sie treiben.
Und ich hab's noch zu Puppke-Zeiten gesagt.
Als Puppke grad den Ultra-Hype hat, ich hab gesagt, Leute, ich geh davon aus, demnächst wird Fortnite vorne sein.
Und das war dann auch so.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, Maxi ist der große Prophet, aber es gibt halt einfach Sachen, die sind irgendwie,
wenn man ein bisschen,
wenn man ein bisschen langjährige Erfahrung in Games hat, drängen sich auf gewisse Vermutungen, ja.
Ich hab auch oft genug falsch gelegen.
Ich hab zum Beispiel Rainbow Six nach Release, also Siege, komplett wieder abgeschrieben.
Da haben sie gezeigt, hey, da kann man durchaus noch was draus machen.
Aber, also, ist jetzt schwer zu sagen, aber wir können's nicht überprüfen.
Aber ich könnte fast wetten, wenn mir einer...
Und wir müssen das echt mal für nächstes Jahr machen.
Ich guck mir 20 Gaming-Projekte an und ich kann euch sagen, ob das was taugt am Ende oder nicht.
Also, mein persönlicher Eindruck, vielleicht denk ich da aber auch, dass ich zu big brain bin,
ist, dass ich relativ oft richtig liege.
Ich hab auch schon beim ersten Anthem-Trailer gesagt, Alter, das wird nix, Leute.
... ist inaccurate, or that they have different plans,
leading people to believe that it might actually be Dice's Brain.
And if that is the case, I hope that Dice has some decent patches planned to span the gap,
adding a permanent TDM-Game-Mode and improving general matchmaking to avoid repeat matches,
for the ability to unsh...
Das muss ich mir grad nochmal anhören, ich hab mir richtig zugehört.
Wisst ihr, was die Fanboys da sagen?
So nach dem Motto, ähm, das gibt in dem Spiel nix.
Die sagen, ja, dann erstell doch einen Portal-Server.
Ja, klar, Portal ist ja die Antwort für alles, ne?
... Plan.
And if that is the case, I hope that Dice has some decent patches planned to span the gap,
adding a permanent TDM-Game-Mode and improving general matchmaking to avoid repeat matches,
for the ability to uncheck maps that you don't wanna play,
would really help reduce some of the...
Einfach es...
Ich bin ja schon so weit in dem Spiel, dass ich sage, es muss kein Server-Browser sein.
Eigentlich müsste es ein Server-Browser sein.
Aber wir werden ja...
Wir werden ja schon damit geholfen, könnte man einfach Maps abwählen, die man nicht spielen will.
Das Problem ist nur, dass fast alle Maps scheiße sind.
Was für Maps bleibt denn noch übrig, die man spielen will?
Was, was, was bleibt übrig?
Was von den Maps willst du wirklich auf diesen offenen, heli-verseuchten Maps spielen?
Wenn du Battlefield-Infanterie-Spieler bist.
Was, was, was willst du tun, würde der echte Gangster jetzt sagen?
Am ehesten noch...
Manifest und Orbital oder sowas.
Aber selbst die sind mittlerweile, ähm, nicht mehr richtig spielbar.
Eigentlich keine, wenn wir mal ehrlich sind.
Welche will man spielen?
Scoreboard! Legacy-Feature!
So, now that we have hindsight on the game's launch,
I think there's some things we can say,
with almost 100% certainty, about what happened.
Firstly, 2042 launched early, and could have used more time.
Ach, nee...
I don't think I'm going out on a limb there, making that statement.
Aber wir sind doch ahead of schedule!
There's many debates as to how much time the game could have needed.
Mindestens ein Jahr.
Ich sag euch, mindestens ein Jahr.
Und dann aber auch nur, unter der Voraussetzung,
man hätte das Game zu einem guten Battlefield noch umkrempeln wollen.
Dann ein Jahr.
Mindestens.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Selbst schuld.
Das war überhaupt nicht getestet.
Da war nichts getestet richtig dran.
Aber wozu sollte man auch Geld fürs Testen ausgeben,
wenn man doch jetzt ein paar hunderttausend quasi kostenlose Tester hat?
Nicht nur kostenlose Tester,
sogar Tester, die Geld dafür bezahlen, Tester zu sein.
Ja, gut.
Aber die Maps sind auch mit 64 Spielern scheiße.
Kann man ja gerade ausprobieren.
Chat, das ist der beste Controller.
Wenn man keine Fehler macht, dann muss man auch nicht testen vorher.
Also man sieht, Battlefield 2042 ist die schwedische Art,
keine Fehler zu machen.
Wenn ich nicht wisse, was die sonst noch so treiben mit Schweden,
wenn das die Art ist, keine Fehler zu machen.
Ich sehe das nicht so positiv.
Aber es gibt auch einige Hauptstücke, wie zum Beispiel ein Scoreboard.
Das wäre eine tolle Qualität.
Ich gehe davon aus, das Spiel ist komplette Totgeburt.
Die werden irgendwann Sommer nächsten Jahres ankündigen,
dass das, äh...
Ja, die können ja schlecht aus der Nummer raus.
Also die Mindestsachen, die sie versprochen haben, werden sie bringen.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass nächstes Jahr im Sommer
oder dahin nochmal versucht wird,
mit quasi hinterhergeworfenen Battlefields,
mit 2042 Lizenzen oder Keys und Downloads,
da noch ein bisschen was rumzureißen.
Und dann wird spätestens Ende des Sommers oder Anfang des Winters,
wenn absehbar ist, dass da nichts mehr geht,
wird verkündet werden, die Zukunftspläne für das Spiel.
Und das wird dann so schön, wie sie es immer machen, umschrieben.
Es wird dann nicht gesagt, Leute, wir stellen den Support ein.
Es ist ja der...
Also der Trend aktuell ist ja,
quasi nicht das zu sagen, was man eigentlich sagen will.
Also, wenn man sagen will heutzutage, Marketing-Strongstechnisch,
ähm, wir stellen den Support für Battlefield ein,
dann schreibt man nicht, wir stellen den Support für Battlefield ein.
Nein, man schreibt, man hat die beste Community und...
Battlefield hat genau Great Future Ahead, schreiben sie.
Genau, das wollte ich gerade sagen.
Die schreiben dann, das Spiel hat eine großartige Zukunft vor sich.
Ihr müsst euch mal die Meldung beispielsweise von Blizzard angucken,
wo sie über Nacht Heroes of the Storm E-Sport eingestampft haben.
Das ist auch so ein Bullshit-Text gewesen.
Ja, das ist, das ist heute so.
Du schreibst nicht, du stellst den Support für das Game ein.
Du schreibst, dass das Game eine tolle Zukunft vor sich hat
und du weiterhin voll committed bist.
Und so ein Bullshit?
Aber zwischen den Zeilen kann jeder erkennen,
das Spiel ist dead.
Und...
Ich denke mal, dass spätestens Ende nächsten Jahres,
aber ich denke schon fast, wechsel so,
Herbst Richtung Winter nächsten Jahres,
wenn es denn so ist, dass es sich im Sommer nicht hat retten lassen
oder gefangen hat oder noch ein paar, äh, verramschte Copys
das jetzt rumreißen können,
dass das dann schon nächstes Jahr soweit sein wird.
Ah, sie müssen das Mindeste liefern, was sie zahlen.
Das ist, was sie zugesichert haben.
Das werden sie wahrscheinlich auch machen.
Aber wir werden es spätestens Ende nächsten Jahres sehen,
wenn halt der Plan kommt, wie es weiterlaufen soll.
Naja, also ich denke, das ist...
Es ist eigentlich schon gelaufen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das Spiel davon wirklich wieder erholen wird.
Kann sein, dass ich fallen schliege.
Mit Rainbow Six habe ich auch komplett daneben gelegen.
Da habe ich auch gedacht, alter, Totgeburt.
Aber ich bin mir bei Battlefield deutlich sicherer als bei Rainbow Six,
weil ich es eben selbst ausführlich gespielt habe.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich denke nicht, dass sie die Kurve bekommen.
Ich glaube, das ist vorbei.
...Eingriffen.
Es wurde auch bemerkt, dass Battlefield 2042
seine Spielbasis ziemlich schnell verloren hat.
Ja.
Die letzte Verkaufszeit und das kostenlose Wochenende
haben es ziemlich stark erhöht.
Das sieht...
Oder hat es hier auch nur auf sieben Tage?
Leute, ich habe das ja eben hier mal offen...
Gehst du fort?
Ich habe das ja hier mal offen gehabt eben.
Ähm...
Moment. Ha!
Nicht New World!
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Äh...
Ich habe es ja eben...
...
Ich habe es ja eben offen gehabt.
Wenn du das mal hier hinstellst, das ist halt richtig krass.
Das geht von 100.000 hier...
...
... runter auf ungefähr 11.000.
Und dann kommt hier Free Weekend.
Die Spielerzahlen sollten dich aber insofern jucken,
wenn du dir weitere Patches und Content für das Spiel erwartest.
Das kann man ja nicht...
...
was a substantial drop overall.
And it's not to say that other big AAA-Titles
with big marketing pre-launch
don't lose a lot of their player base after launch.
This one's just been a little more drastic.
To put things into more context,
Halo Infinite, which has been extremely well received overall,
lost 72% of its player base in a pretty comparable...
Da, das ist richtig,
da würde mich aber in dem Fall tatsächlich mal die Xbox-Zahlen interessieren,
weil Halo schon seit Jahren ein Xbox-Ding ist.
Aber ja, hey, es ist auch kein Wunder, dass Halo das...
Ja, Halo kommt gut an, aber es ist auch kein Wunder,
dass Halo Spielerzahlen verliert.
Die machen auch nicht wirklich genug, um die Spieler zu halten.
Die haben ein komisches Event gestartet,
was jetzt nicht sonderlich gut angekommen ist,
und haben einen Season Pass, der hat zwar coole Dinger,
aber 90% davon sind dann auch Trash.
Also, das wundert mich jetzt auch nicht.
Und New World hat 90% verloren.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Battlefield hat 90% verloren.
Die sind runter von 100.000 auf 10.000, 11.000.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen,
das macht es ja nicht besser,
nur weil andere Spiele auch abkacken.
Ja, da bleibt uns ja nichts anderes übrig.
Tommy, kann ich verstehen, kann ich verstehen.
Ich habe New World ja auch zur Belustigung verfolgt.
Ich habe New World, die BTW,
gespielt und im Prinzip kann es jeder sich mal im Video anhören.
Auch so ein Ding, genau das, was ich in meinem Video gesagt habe,
von wegen Endgame-Content und sonst was,
genau so ist es ja dann im Endeffekt im Spiel auch gewesen.
Habe ich ja auch richtig gelegen mit.
Und ich habe New World verfolgt,
weil ich New World sehr witzig fand,
die Phase, wo jeden Tag neue Game-Breaking-Bugs rausgekommen sind
und wo Amazon es quasi tagtäglich verkackt hat
mit irgendwelchen Patches.
Patches, die andere Sachen kaputt gemacht haben
und Sachen, die sie fixen wollten, nicht richtig gefixt haben.
Spielertransfere, wo Gold dupliziert werden konnte und sonst was.
Ich habe täglich, ist ungelungen,
ich habe täglich, bestimmt drei, vier Wochen lang,
täglich New World News verfolgt.
Ich hing den quasi an den Lippen,
den Leuten, die New World News gemacht haben auf YouTube,
weil ich das so unterhaltsam fand,
den kompletten Cluster-Fuck und die Fuck-Ups von Amazon zu sehen
bei New World.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die ganze Community-Sentiment,
wiederum, die Leute sind immer noch sehr dividiert.
Es gibt definitiv viele Leute, die einfach nur wütend sind
über das Spiel und einige der Design-Decisions,
und einige der Performance-Probleme,
besonders auf den letzten-Gen-Consolen.
Aber für die Leute, die das Spiel genießen,
und ich bin in dieser Kategorie,
muss ich sagen, es ist eigentlich
ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich lustig.
Und ich mag es nicht, dass ich mich schuldig fühle,
dass ich sagen muss, dass ich es genieße.
Nein, musst du auch nicht.
Wenn es dir Spaß macht, ist ja gut.
Dann kriegst du wenigstens ein bisschen was von deinem Geld.
Gut, du hast wahrscheinlich genauso wenig auch einen Kiki gekriegt.
Aber das ist ja okay.
Man will ja keinem ein schlechtes Gewissen machen,
weil er das Spiel gut findet.
Aber trotzdem heißt das nicht,
dass das Spiel keine Probleme hat.
Das muss man ja immer trennen.
Das fällt mir bei Sachen, die ich gut finde,
auch immer schwierig.
Fällt mir auch immer schwer bei Sachen,
die ich persönlich richtig gut finde,
dass man sagt, ja, okay, ich habe da vielleicht mal einen Spaß dran,
aber trotzdem darf man nicht die Augen davor verletzen,
dass es erstens bei ganz vielen Leuten eben nicht der Fall ist
und vor allem auch, warum das so ist.
Also, man muss dann schon sehen,
okay, das Spiel hat viele Probleme.
Und ich sehe daraus,
darf das Spiel natürlich jedem weiterhin Spaß machen.
Also, New World finde ich weitaus schlimmer als Battlefield 2042.
Ah ja, das stimmt. Gut.
Ich meine, New World ist ja nur wirklich absolute Untergrenze,
die du ja kaum noch unterschreiten kannst.
Aber vor ein paar Jahren
hätte sich das sicherlich keiner denken lassen,
dass Battlefield mal bei so einem Ding,
bei so einem All-Time-Battlefield-Low ankommt.
Aber Battlefield ist auch schon ganz schön, ganz schön weit unten.
Ja, es ist nicht so beschissen gelaufen wie New World.
Aber, also, es ist verfasst,
es ist ja fast dieses Jahr ein Wettbewerb,
allerdings nicht nach oben,
sondern wer schlechter sein kann.
Ja, dann kommt Amazon, macht New World,
dann sagt DICE, ah, wir können auch.
Dann kommt Vanguard um die Ecke, ach, wir können auch.
Ach, was gab es denn sonst noch dieses Jahr?
Für komische Dinge.
WOLZEN, alter!
Kannst du dich noch ein bisschen an Wolcen erinnern?
Es war doch dieses Jahr, oder?
War doch Anfang des Jahres...
WOLZEN?
Cyberpunk...
... war Ende letzten Jahresjahr?
WOLZEN?
Das kennt wahrscheinlich gar keiner mehr.
So schnell ist der Hype gestorben bei Wolzen.
Ich weiß übrigens gar nicht bis heute,
wie man Wolzen überhaupt ausspricht.
Ich meine, dieses Diablo-Klon-Ding.
Wolzen ?
Wo, Woorsen,
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man das ausspricht.
Oh man, egal.
Weiter.
Ja, Nintendo kackt ja auch wohl öfters ab in letzter Zeit.
Also es ist wirklich,
dieses Jahr und auch in den letzten Jahren,
es ist eher so ein Race to the Bottom sozusagen.
Und nicht, wer ist besser.
Die Forged, Warcraft 3, die Forged,
gab es ja auch noch.
Aber das ist letztes Jahr, das lassen wir jetzt mal außen vor.
Wenn es danach geht, gab es ja noch mehr.
Von Fallout 76 und Anthem
und dem ganzen Geschiss reden wir mal gar nicht.
Ich reg mich auf, wenn ich spielen muss.
Ich meine,
allein schon das da.
Warum, warum
ist der Spot hier mit dem
Sniper?
Sniper direkt im Gegnerspawn.
Ich meine, was ist das für eine Map?
Also ich weiß, wie die Map heißt.
Ich meine, was ist das für ein Map-Design?
Was ist da Gegnerspawn?
Die Helis sind gestört.
Brutal in dem Spiel.
Ja.
Es ist möglich, dass ein Klassen-System nicht auf die Straße kommt, aber wer weiß.
Die Verlängerung der Waffen-Variante in dem Spiel beginnt ein bisschen zu wehren.
Du bist auf die Firma von Dr. Disrespect gespannt, ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie einen Shooter entwickeln.
Aber was wir nicht vergessen dürfen, Dr. Disrespect war Level-Designer für Modern Warfare 3.
Oder Ghosts?
Was, wo war der nochmal dabei?
Bei Ghosts, oder?
Bei Alien Call of Duty war der dabei, ob das so viel besser wird, mal gucken.
Ja, war er.
Könnt ihr nachgucken, gibt immer noch Leute, die da jedes Mal überrascht sind.
Aber ich dachte eigentlich, das ist mittlerweile ein bekannter Fact, aber Dr. Disrespect, Level-Designer für...
Ja, das ist er.
Okay, er war in MW3 und Advanced Warfare beteiligt anscheinend, oder?
Ja, Modern Warfare 3 und Advanced Warfare war er am Start.
Advanced Warfare, ja.
Mal gucken, ob er das jetzt besser hinkriegt.
Okay, Level-Cap, lehnt jetzt wieder im Kreis rum.
Oh ne, Hazard Zone.
Hazard Zone.
Hazard Zone, null.
Null, Hazard Zone.
Null W.
Null HD.
Null 4K.
Null 8K.
Null 420, Hazard Zone.
Ja.
welches natürlich ein bisschen mehr Beschleunigung bewirkt, weil jetzt DICE...
Sie müssen wirklich nur ihre Live-Service-Inhalte aus dem Park schicken,
anstatt nur akzeptable Inhalte zu liefern.
Zum Glück haben wir noch nie diesen furchtbaren Santa-Skin gesehen.
Also sind mir die Finger geklopft, dass es nicht wirklich geplant war,
oder vielleicht sollte es nur eine Linie-Zeit gewesen sein,
oder vielleicht wird DICE es immer noch eröffnen.
DICE hat einen süßen kleinen Infektions-Modus mit Elfen und Candy-Canes gemacht.
Und das Gute daran ist, dass...
DICE hat in der letzten Folge mit DICE zuerst das einzige Spiel, das sie überhaupt nicht haben konnte.
Aber die Spiele sind jetzt erst mal komplett weggegangen.
Und jetzt haben wir noch einen neuen Spiel, der zum Zeitpunkt der Spiel-Saison für DICE-Serie kommt.
Der erste Spiel ist...
DICE TRIP TO THE WEST
Ja, Tommy, das kenne ich.
Hackerman-Time.
Hackermans.
Den USB-Stick hatte auch schon jeder.
Ja.
Ist laut genug.
Erki, danke für den Zap.
So müsste es aber eigentlich passen, oder?
Nee, dazu habe ich mich schon nicht weiter belesen.
All about strategy.
Nee.
Oh, nice.
Darf ich das auf Streamen?
Darf ich das streamen, wie ich meine PS4 jailbreake?
Bestimmt nicht, oder?
Darf, ich glaube, das darf man nicht streamen, wenn man seine Konsole jailbreakt.
Was kann man mit einem modded PS4 machen?
Nun, du hast vielleicht gehört über Dinge wie, dass man PT runnen kann, oder Bloodborne
bei 60 FPS.
Nun, du kannst das machen, und du kannst ein paar mehr machen.
Und in diesem Episode gehen wir durch einige der coolen Dinge, die man mit einem modded
PS4 runnen kann, 9.00.
Aber zuerst, lass uns schnell über den Exploit sprechen und wie es alles funktioniert.
The Jailbreak was released on December the 13th with the following note.
In this project, you will find an implementation that tries to make use of a file system bug
for the PlayStation 4 on firmware 9.00.
It will require a drive with a modified exfat file system.
Oh, big brain time jetzt.
Successfully triggering it will allow you to run arbitrary code as kernel, allowing
jailbreak...
Ja, das hast du gewonnen.
... breaking and kernel-level modifications.
Now, running the jailbreak is pretty simple.
I don't want to cover it here, because guides like this tend to go out of date fast.
But if you want a step-by-step guide to jailbreaking your PS4 running 9.00, I will leave links
to both Modded Warfare and Mr. Mario 2011.
Ist das hier im Hintergrund nicht diese Silent Hill Demo, wo das Spiel nie dazu erschienen
ist?
Ja, das ist das.
Ja, das ist was anderes.
Ja.
Ja, das war der erste PS-Oberstart.
Standalone Jailbreak. It requires a USB flash drive as well as a PC to push the payload.
Gut, ich glaube ein USB Stick und ein PC um das drauf zu machen, das haben die meisten Leute.
Zumindest alle die daran denken ihre PS4 zu jailbreaken.
Shut down the PlayStation 4, you will need to run the exploit again. But in my experience,
so far at least, I've had success putting my PS4 into rest mode and powering it back on,
it will remain exploited. It's not ideal but it works. And to be honest, the success rate of
this exploit is so good, that it's not really a huge deal running it over and over again if
you need to. Now once you are running gold hand, you can push other payloads to the PS4.
And let me tell you, you'll want to do this. Because things like game dumping tools,
trainers and much more are at your disposal. So we've successfully jailbroken our 9.0
Firmware Playstation 4. We've successfully jailbroken our 9.0 Firmware Playstation 4.
So we've successfully jailbroken our 9.0 Firmware Playstation 4.
Wie alt ist der 9.0 als Firmware?
Also wie gesagt, ich hatte meine Playstation 4 bestimmt zwei Jahre nicht mehr an.
Ich habe das noch, ich habe das noch auf meiner, ich glaube ich hatte das auf der PS3 damals sogar drauf.
Oder war das PS4? Ich habe die Demo noch drauf auf meiner Playstation.
Let's up the ante a little. Because the jailbreak is running on Firmware 9, this means that you can pretty much dump the entire contents of disks to an external USB drive like this one here.
Even current releases like Ghost of Tsushima will run on Firmware 9.
Die ich von meinen eigenen Datenträgern ohne Umgehung des Kopierschutzes erstellt habe.
Auf andere Ideen würde ich nicht kommen. Oder Linux-Distributionen über Torrent runterladen.
Du kannst, also jetzt mal unabhängig davon, das einfachste, was du, das generellste, was du machen kannst nach einem Jailbreak ist, du kannst Custom-Software ausführen.
Das kann alles sein im Endeffekt.
... Firmware 9 without any updates.
Now a specific payload known as AppDumper.
Will dump the contents of the currently running disk-based game, where then you can use tools in your PC to create what is known as a fake package file.
Via this package file you can install this file back onto your jailbroken PS4 without ever requiring the disk again.
One of the things I really like to mess around with on a modded PS4 is the ability to use trainers.
Now this is obviously something you can do to apply cheats to certain games.
Und there is...
Ich würde mich die ganzen Leute in Multiplayer-Spielen drüber freuen.
... a particular website out there that has cheats for pretty much any PlayStation 4 game on the market.
Activating trainers on your jailbroken PS4 is pretty easy to do.
First you need to...
Wie ist das eigentlich?
Ähm, wie sieht das eigentlich, Chat?
Wie sieht es mit Warzone auf der PS5 aus?
Gibt's das da schon?
Oder spielen die noch alle PS4?
Dann sind die Hackermans jetzt ja überall.
Kann man mit Jailbreak überhaupt noch...
...online spielen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wenn die...
Wenn die, ähm...
...Firmaversion zu alt ist, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung.
Also, bei manchen Konsolen ja, bei manchen nein.
Ja, also zum Beispiel...
Zum Beispiel bei der Xbox 360 mit nem, äh...
...Mod-Chip...
...konntest du online spielen.
Wurdest aber höchstwahrscheinlich gebannt.
Ah, du musst den PSN-Server ploppen wegen Updates.
Okay.
...Games that you wanna play cheats to, then run a payload known as WebRTE 900.
From here, simply browse to a website that contains all the games that have trainers and then search for your game.
Gut, das würd mich jetzt...
...das würd mich persönlich jetzt nicht so shoppen.
Gut, man könnte damit wahrscheinlich, äh, PSN-Trophies machen, indem man die offline unlockt und danach updatet.
...apply.
For example, in Final Fantasy VII Remake, I can easily enable things like Unlimited Gil and Max HP.
And then from here, I can just go...
...back into my game and play as normal.
Ob das...
...ob das jemals fertig wird?
Das Final Fantasy VII Remake?
Ich mein, die haben jetzt Remake quasi...
...das...
...ich sag mal übertrieben, das Intro des Spiels haben die jetzt über fünf Jahre oder so remaked.
Der riesengroße Teil des Games ist ja da noch nicht mal im Ansatz zu erkennen.
Who goes there?
Ob das jemals fertig wird?
You're up.
...or how about...
Ja gut, das interessiert mich jetzt nicht.
Ja, das geht im Prinzip immer noch.
Moment, warum läuft da Half-Life drauf auf der PS?
...of course, Retro Arc on the PS4 is pretty good as you would expect.
And everything that is downloaded from the Homebrew Store will be downloaded and installed as package...
...ist...
...das ist Blue Shift, oder?
Ja, das ist Blue Shift.
...simply just go into your UI and launch the game as you normally would.
Now, it does go without saying that...
...there is...
...interessant, hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass man mittlerweile auch schon halbwegs aktuelle Playstations modden kann.
Oder Jailbreaking.
Wahrscheinlich.
Mal gucken.
Remake 2, Part 2, wie sieht's denn damit aus?
Release Date Character.
Das ist wieder so eine Seite, die random Scheiß hinschreibt, obwohl sie es selbst nicht besser weiß.
Huge Rumors.
Ja, oder ein Huge Rumor.
Teil 2 gibt's dann 2030.
Und das heißt, das Spiel ist dann irgendwann mal fertig.
2045 oder so.
Ich glaub ja nicht, dass das jemals wird.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, sowas mach ich nicht.
Wenn es Toss ist, mach ich das nicht, wär ich ja blöd.
Keine Chance.
Was können wir uns sonst noch angucken?
Wir gucken uns das Video von Maurice an.
Da...
...der...
...dem...
Da stimme ich meistens zu bei solchen Sachen.
Auf Maurice, erzähl uns...
...die Neuigkeiten.
Ja.
Und ich bin ja auch egal.
Naja, kommt drauf an, mein Geld ist ihr nicht egal.
Ich schon.
How can you even consider that?
Wenn ihr also dachtet, das Spielejahr 2021 war schon richtig schlimm,
dann stellt euch darauf ein, dass 2022...
Nicht besser wird.
...mindestens genauso schlimm, wenn nicht wahr, noch schlimmer wird.
Sehe ich genauso.
Man kann das sehr gut daran festmachen.
Dass wir ja vermutlich alle früher mal diesen einen Lieblingsentwickler hatten, von dem wir jedes Spiel guten Gewissens...
Also mein, mein mit Abstand Lieblingsentwickler, wisst ihr ja alle, ist, ich finde ihn immer nicht in meinen Emotes, selbstverständlich Lord Gaben, blind gekauft haben.
Und wenn man sich heute fragt, welchem dieser Entwickler von früher kann man heute noch...
Keinem.
...genau so blind vertrauen, dann bleibt nicht mehr viel...
Na gut, sagen wir mal so, die von früher nicht, ja, aber es gibt durchaus, und das muss ich mir auch selbst immer wieder so in Erinnerung rufen,
gerade wenn man auf Steam guckt, bei Games jetzt nicht von riesengroßen Studios, da gibt es durchaus gute Games.
Nee, Nintendo, Quatsch, was meinst du, was bei Nintendo abgeht und wie die Leute sich da überschlagen,
bei den Pokémon Games, dass die alles sacken zum größten Teil.
Nee, nee, bei Nintendo ist es auch schon...
...schon lange nichts mehr mit, du kannst dich darauf verlassen, dass da was Gutes rauskommt.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Ja, also es gibt, es gibt ja immer noch gute Spiele, es geht ja hauptsächlich um Triple-A-Titel, jetzt auch wahrscheinlich, denke ich mal, dass es ihnen in dem Video da zum größten Teil darum geht, wo du zum größten Teil nur noch verarscht wirst.
Aber es gibt auf Steam immer noch gute Games.
Zum Beispiel eines meiner Lieblingsgames in letzter Zeit...
...das macht wirklich Bock.
Wer auf sowas wie Theme Park oder so steht, ist das wirklich nice.
Ich finde auch den Grafikstil niedlich.
Normalerweise sage ich ja, Alter, es gibt so viele Spiele mit Pixel-Art, aber die haben das wirklich nett gemacht.
Nee, man kann es jetzt natürlich nicht mit Triple-A-Games wie Battlefield oder sowas vergleichen.
Aber ich finde, es macht Spaß.
Also, Kreativität gibt es da ja noch.
Bei mir war es zum Beispiel BioWare, wo ich nach Anthem nie wieder blind kaufen würde.
Bei euch waren es vielleicht Blizzard.
Was macht Anthem 2.0 eigentlich? Das wurde eingestellt, ne?
Ja, ja, stimmt.
Bethesda, CD Projekt, Rockstar, alles Firmen, wo man heute sagen muss...
Dice!
Nee, da muss ich vorsichtiger sein.
Denn es hat sich industrieweit eine neue Mentalität durchgesetzt.
Ja, es haben sich vor allem Stonks Anzugträger...
...in der Chefetage durchgesetzt und keine Gamer mehr.
Erst Spiele...
Blizzard hat früher Spiele quasi von Spielern...
Na gut, von Spielern, für Spieler ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen platt ausgedrückt.
Aber von Gaming-Enthusiasten, von Gamern, die Spiele mögen, für Gamer, die Spiele mögen, entwickelt.
Und wann habt ihr früher Spiele bekommen, zum Beispiel von Blizzard?
Die haben ja geprägt diese Geschichte mit It's Done.
Das gibt's heute nicht mehr.
Heute hauen die so eine Kacke wie Warcraft 3 Deforged raus.
Weil irgendwelche Business-Stonks-Manager gesagt haben, Jungs, jetzt muss es aber mal raus.
Und was die auch gesagt haben ist, das Spiel bleibt jetzt so.
An Warcraft 3, wenn ich das so verfolge, tut sich kaum noch was.
Gibt es in Warcraft 3 eigentlich mittlerweile ohne Third-Party irgendeine gescheite Ladder?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Wahrscheinlich immer noch nicht.
Ich spiel das nicht, aber ich verfolge es immer so ein bisschen am Rande.
Raushauen und wenn sie kaputt sind, dann können wir das immer noch fixen, wenn wir von den Leuten das Geld dafür bekommen.
Ja, oder man lässt es einfach so, wie es ist.
Und man merkt, finde ich, mehr und mehr, das sind keine einzelnen Ausrutscher mehr.
Das ist System.
Die Industrie hat sich in relativ großer Masse dazu entschieden, dass das absolut akzeptabel ist.
Ja, und die Leute machen mit.
Und die Fanboys des Monats.
Die Fans machen mit.
Das ist ja gerade das Schlimme.
Das ist das, was ich auch in meinem Video gesagt habe, wo es um Battlefield 2042 ging.
Dass umso mehr man das akzeptiert, umso mehr wird es das geben.
Das muss eigentlich jedem klar sein.
Und es ist ja wohl akzeptiert genug, sonst könnte man das nicht machen.
Und auch CD Projekt Red, die ja nun mit den Witcher Games und sowas sich einen schon ganz guten Ruf aufgebaut haben,
haben das halt mit einem Schlag.
Und Cyberpunk versaut.
Cyberpunk, dass das in dieser Art und Weise rausgekommen ist, war auch eine reine Stonks Geldentscheidung.
Mehrere Gründe dafür, die zum Teil sogar irgendwo nachvollziehbar und legitim sind.
Ein Grund ist, dass Corona natürlich die Spielentwicklung, die davor schon eine sehr komplexe, komplizierte Aufgabe war,
noch weiter erschwert hat, weil Firmen teils mitten in der Entwicklung...
Aber die Ansätze waren ja vorher auch...
... auch schon da.
... von den Spielen, die jetzt rausgekommen sind, wie zum Beispiel Battlefield, ins Homeoffice wechseln mussten und ihre komplette Firmen- und Kommunikationsstruktur...
Ja, die hatten mega Probleme bei Battlefield in der Entwicklung.
Das haben wir ja auch in dem Video letztens gesehen und das haben wir uns im Vorfeld ja auch schon gedacht.
Da haben aber aus meiner Sicht Projektmanager verkackt bei.
Erstens, die sind dafür da, die bekommen dafür Geld, um solche Probleme zu lösen.
Und wie gesagt, die Ansätze in die Richtung, wie sich das entwickelt hat, die waren ja auch vor Corona.
Die waren ja alle schon da.
Ich meine, man denke mal an das letzte Star Wars Battlefront.
Das war vor Corona.
Und ich glaube, da kann sich noch jeder dran erinnern.
Fallout 76 war auch vor Corona.
Also das ist nichts, was durch Corona ausgelöst wurde.
Manchmal ist es vielleicht auch so, dass der Publisher entscheidet, obwohl der Entwickler sogar sagen würde,
Leute, wir brauchen noch mehr Zeit, wir müssen das weiter entwickeln.
Aber der Publisher hat jahrelang schon Marketingpläne konzipiert, die sich nicht mehr so leicht verschieben lassen.
Möglicherweise machen die Aktionäre Druck, die jetzt das Weihnachtsgeschäft mitnehmen wollen, damit die Aktionäre...
Normalerweise muss ich über Grafikletches nicht lachen, weil ich habe da schon mehr oder weniger alles gesehen
und ich sehe meistens so einfach irgendwelche Verpackengraben, aber das finde ich tatsächlich doch witzig.
Oder möglicherweise geht halt auch schlichtweg das Geld aus und die Entwicklung kann nicht fortgesetzt werden.
Das passiert bei...
...großen Studios genau wie bei kleinen.
Es ist gar nicht so, dass das nur die großen bösen Firmen wie EA sind, die dann eben zum Beispiel ein Battlefield unfertig raushauen.
Das passiert genauso bei Wolcen oder The Ascended, also eher kleineren Rollenspielen,
die ebenfalls in richtig blödem Zustand erschienen sind in den letzten Jahren.
Und es scheint mir eben schon so, dass bei allen Aspekten...
Sekunde!
...die da...
Spielt überhaupt noch jemand Wolcen? Das hatten wir uns auch letztens...
Nee, hatten wir uns nicht.
Steam Stats Wolcen.
300 Spieler.
Ah! 304! Immerhin!
Ja, von 127.000 Peak.
Nice.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Exzellent.
Hier Wolcen.
Oh, was...
...gewissermaßen schon auch nachvollziehbar sind, weil Spieleentwicklung ist auch ein Geschäft und Geld ist nicht unbegrenzt.
Klar.
Aber genau so beobachte ich da schon mehr und mehr, dass Firmen auch für sich entschieden haben...
Wir brauchen...
Es ist okay.
...die Scheiße zu produzieren.
...einen guten Ruf bei unseren Fans, bei unseren Spielern.
Und du hast trotzdem, das ist ja das, was mich immer so wahnsinnig anpisst,
du hast trotzdem immer noch die Hardcore-Fanboys, die das alles bis aufs Blut verteidigen,
so als hättest du ihre Mutter beleidigt, wenn du was über ihr Game sagst.
Und das sind die eigentlichen Leute, die richtig lost sind.
...zu machen.
Und es gibt ein paar Vorfälle in den letzten Jahren, die das für mich besonders klar gemacht haben.
Einer ist zum Beispiel die Konsolen-Version von Cyberpunk.
Oh nein, die PS4-Version.
Wo man, finde ich, einfach sehr klar festhalten muss, das kann kein Versehen gewesen sein.
Nö.
Vor allem nicht, dass die Firmenspitze noch kurz vor Release Äußerungen rausgehauen hat, wie das läuft überraschend gut.
Und hinterher...
Ich sag nur, way ahead of schedule bei Battlefield.
...sagt hat, wir haben es released, weil wir ehrlich gedacht haben, wir schaffen es bis zum Release noch.
Was, also eine von diesen beiden Aussagen kann ja nicht stimmen.
Es gibt keinen Sinn, wie das spricht sich.
Weil entweder habt ihr vor Release gedacht, es läuft überraschend gut,
oder ihr habt gedacht, Leute, wir schaffen das bis zum Release noch.
Ihr könnt ja nicht beides gedacht haben.
Entweder gab es noch was zu schaffen.
Doch, doch, die Entwickler haben wahrscheinlich gebetet, wir schaffen das zum Release noch.
Und die Marketing-Stonks-Leute haben den Käufern irgendwelchen Dummschmus erzählt,
dass sie doch jetzt mal mehr Geld reinstecken.
Oder es war alles super.
Nie im Leben haben sie unwissentlich diese miserable Konsolen-Version veröffentlicht.
Das kann ich mir schlichtweg nicht vorstellen.
Da wurde die Entscheidung getroffen, wir hauen das so raus und wir verheimlichen das vor der Community.
Das war nicht transparent.
Da war egal, dass man sich über Jahre einen Ruf als eine der wenigen letzten Spieler- und Community-freundlichen Entwickler aufgebaut hat.
Da ging es ums Geld.
Da hat man drauf geschissen.
Das sieht man auch bei anderen Firmen.
Blizzard hat entschieden, Warcraft 3 Reforged nicht nur so rauszuhauen, wie es erschienen ist,
sondern vor allem auch einfach so zu lassen.
Blizzard hat jetzt eins der am schlechtesten bewerteten Metacritic-Spiele aller Zeiten in seinen...
Äh, Fezzix, ja.
Das ist halt im Business-Bereich so.
Das ist die Realität.
Das, was intern der wirkliche Zustand eines Produkts ist und das, was kommuniziert wird,
sind zwei verschiedene.
Das ist die pedal-Rstutturgie, die in der Regel bei der Automatisierung so in einen Blick gesetzt wird,
dass die Ferrassenträger profitieren.
Und der große Unterschied ist dann, dass die Fehlerstage eigentlich schnell abgelöscht werden.
Und da wird dann wieder, wie gesagt, einiges nicht gemacht.
Weißt du, was das bedeutet?
Es ist ein Stichwort.
Du hast nicht genau das Gefühl, dass du die Fehler auf sich hast,
dass du den Fehler auf dich hast.
Weil du das nicht hättest, weil du sagtest,
das war jetzt vielleicht eine weitere Möglichkeit.
So, was sind die Fehler?
Es sind also Steckmaße.
Garantiert nicht. Also das sind ja auch nur Menschen alles.
Und in der Regel möchte man, dass das, was man quasi unter viel Arbeitseinsatz gebaut hat, gut ankommt.
Also die finden es sicherlich nicht geil.
Einem Portfolio als Teil der Firmengeschichte und das Blizzard Management oder das Activision Blizzard Management,
wer auch immer das war, hat entschieden, das ist okay.
Es ist den Aufwand nicht wert, sowas zu fixen.
Wir lassen dieses schwarze Mal unserer Firmengeschichte jetzt einfach so stehen.
Genau wie EA entschieden hat, ein Flop wie Anthem kann auch bei BioWare jetzt einfach mal so stehen bleiben.
BioWare ebenfalls eine Marke mit früher mal unglaublicher Strahlkraft,
wo sich der Publisher und aktuelle Besitzer EA dann entschieden hat,
passt schon, wenn da so ein Flop wie Anthem mit dabei ist.
Und das wäre doch früher unvorstellbar gewesen,
dass bei Firmen wie Blizzard,
BioWare oder Blizzard oder CD Projekt
solche Entscheidungen getroffen werden.
Ich würde nicht vergessen, dass Leute, die Spiele wie Dragon Age 1 gemacht haben,
was meiner Meinung nach mit Abstand das beste Dragon Age Game ist,
ist Addon mal außen vor, aber das Main Game Dragon Age Origins ist richtig gut.
Einfach sagt, ist doch egal, was die Leute sagen werden.
Und ich will damit klarstellen, mir ist absolut bewusst,
und das sollten auch sich Leute da draußen bewusst machen, die diese Entscheidungen kritisieren.
Sind das überhaupt noch die gleichen Developer vom Namen her noch,
von den Leuten, die da sind, wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil nicht mehr.
Werden diese Entscheidungen nicht von den einzelnen Entwicklern getroffen.
Das sind nicht die Grafiker, das sind nicht die Level Designer,
das sind nicht die Quest Autoren, die entscheiden,
das ist klar, wir hauen das raus und fixen es hinterher nicht.
Das sind Leute im höheren Management, die mehr auf den Aktienkurs und die pure Rentabilität schauen,
als darauf, was das Anständige, das Korrekte gegenüber der Community ist.
Genau. Als darauf, was das Anständige, das Korrekte gegenüber der Community ist.
Als darauf, was das Anständige, das Korrekte gegenüber der Community ist.
Und manchmal ist es ja auch so...
Die interessieren sich ja auch einen Scheiß für die Community.
Das geht denen am Arsch vorbei.
Meint ihr wirklich, dass jemand...
Das kommt ja öfters vor.
Die stellen sich auf die Bühne und sagen,
wir möchten uns bei allen unseren Fans bedanken.
Wir haben die besten Fans, die man sich wünschen kann.
Danke Leute, ihr seid die Besten.
Sowas in der Richtung. Sagen die ja gerne auf irgendwelchen Veranstaltungen.
Meint ihr wirklich, irgendjemand,
dieser Anzugtypen, der da vorne auf der Bühne steht,
meint das wirklich ernst, was er da sagt?
Meint ihr wirklich, irgendjemand, dieser Anzugtypen, der da vorne auf der Bühne steht,
das ist denen so scheißegal?
Zum Beispiel bei Cyberpunk gibt es ja Bemühungen,
zum Beispiel bei Cyberpunk gibt es ja Bemühungen,
das Spiel hinterher zu fixen.
Aber dass allein die Entscheidung getroffen wurde,
diese Konsolenversion, hauen wir erstmal so raus.
Das spricht für mich halt wirklich...
Wieso bekommen die noch Geld?
Ich glaube, das ist einmal eine Mischung.
Es gibt halt mehrere Gründe.
Viele befinden sich noch ein bisschen
in der Phase der Realität.
In der Phase der Realitätsverweigerung.
Viele Leute sagen jetzt,
ich habe jetzt Entwickler XY
über Jahre die Treue gehalten
und fand das immer gut.
Wenn ich jetzt sage,
das ist quasi nicht mehr gut,
dann würde ich ja in Frage stellen,
habe ich mein Leben nicht verschwendet
die letzten 10 Jahre?
Jetzt übertrieben gesagt,
aber so Gedanken hat man ja.
Es kommt ja öfters vor,
dass man Sachen abstreitet,
weil man dann
sich gleichermaßen eingesteht,
man hat selbst quasi
jahrelang was gemacht,
was eigentlich verschenkt war.
Das ist wie die Leute,
die damals ernsthaft darüber diskutiert haben,
dass auf der PS3 PSN besser ist als Xbox Live.
Das haben die einfach nur...
Die waren so getriggert,
wenn man gesagt hat,
Xbox Live ist besser,
weil sie sich dann quasi automatisch eingestehen mussten,
sie haben vielleicht nicht das Beste,
und vielleicht haben sie sich
für den falschen Kauf entschieden.
Also, genau, Xbox Live war besser,
PSN for free.
Zum Beispiel, gibt noch mehrere Punkte,
übergreifende Partys und was auch immer.
Und dann hätten die sich ja eingestehen müssen,
ey fuck, vielleicht habe ich jetzt meine Oma
zwei Jahre umsonst bearbeitet,
dass die mir das Geld für eine Playstation gibt.
Deswegen sind die Leute
bei solchen Themen
auch immer so emotional ultra getriggert gleich.
Man...
gesteht sich
unglaublich
ungern ein,
wenn man
was ver...
Falsch ist noch nicht mal das richtige Wort.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es nennen soll.
Wenn man...
Wie könnte man das nennen?
Wenn sich im Nachhinein Sachen halt
als nicht so das herausstellen,
was man selbst geglaubt hat
die letzten Jahre über.
Und wenn jetzt einer
seit World of Warcraft Release
übelster Blizzard Fanboy ist.
Und es ihm eigentlich schon
mindestens die letzten fünf Jahre über
klar sein müsste, dass das alte
Blizzard eigentlich nicht mehr da ist.
Dann sagt er sich aber,
hey, ich verschließ da lieber
die Augen immer weiter davor,
weil mit jedem weiteren Tag
müsste ich mir quasi einen längeren
Zeitraum eingestehen,
an dem ich quasi
an das Falsche geglaubt habe, sozusagen.
Und das machen die Leute
nicht gern. Ist ja auch verständlich.
Macht ja keiner gerne.
So, also das ist glaube ich ein Punkt.
Viele befinden sich noch so
in dieser Phase der
Realitätsverweigerung.
Das ist dann so eine Mischung
aus Hardcore-Fanboys und Leuten,
die es einfach nicht wahrhaben wollen.
Dann gibt es ultra viele Casuals,
die von der ganzen Sache gar nichts mitkriegen.
Und sich halt so
mitreißen lassen, so nach dem Motto
Hey, neues Battlefield, richtig krasse, geile Werbung,
guck ich mir mal an, was auch immer.
Und es ist nicht zu unterschätzen, wie viele
Casuals es gibt.
Die Leute, die sich wirklich im Kern oder
tiefer mit Games auseinandersetzen, ist ja
gerade, wenn man guckt in Richtung Mobile Gaming,
komplett die Minderheit.
Kein Wunder, dass Mobile Gaming
so groß ist.
Und das Dritte ist,
es gibt Leute wie mich,
die es eigentlich besser wissen
und sich den Kram trotzdem kaufen,
weil sie es nicht wahrhaben wollen.
Jo gut, eigentlich bin ich auch
eigentlich bin ich auch
und wenn du es so willst,
kannst du mich auch zu Gruppe 1 zählen.
Mir war es eigentlich mehr oder weniger klar,
aber ich habe trotzdem gedacht,
Alter, das könnt ihr doch nicht verkacken.
Und was natürlich auch noch dabei kommt,
Leute sind träge.
Leute sind faul.
Das dauert alles ein bisschen.
Und man kann das
auch nicht nur quasi
immer auf uns schieben
im Endeffekt.
Die Hersteller
versuchen das ja auch
geschickt zu umgehen.
Ihr habt es bei der Marketinggeschichte
von Battlefield 2042 gesehen.
Wie sehr da auf die Gefühlsschiene
für alte Battlefield-Veteranen gesetzt
wurden. Vom Docktag-Messern
bis zum Jeep, der springt und das Flugzeug
in die Luft springt,
bis zum RPG aus dem Jet
und sowas in der Richtung.
Das hat mit dem fertigen Game nichts,
aber auch wieder nichts zu tun.
Das hat man gemacht, um die Veteranen emotional
gezielt anzusprechen.
Weil sie genau wussten,
danach kriegen sie die Leute nicht mehr.
Die machen das schon geschickt.
Das kommt ja auch noch dabei.
So, jetzt wollen wir aber das Video mal weiter gucken.
Wie hoch da die Meinung der Community gewichtet wurde
versus
Stonks! Endlich!
Maurice! Endlich fängt er auch
mit dem passenden Meme dafür an.
Stonks!
Jawoll!
Bester Mann!
PR-Pläne,
Aktionäre, Weihnachtsgeschäft.
Derlei Geschichten.
Und was, finde ich, noch viel schwerer
wiegt, wir sehen das
genauso. Also diese, eine gewisse
Gleichgültigkeit gegenüber
dem, was die Leute da draußen wohl sagen
werden, bei noch viel schlimmeren
Skandalen. Weil ein kaputtes Spiel
ist ja eine Sache.
Gibt man 60 Euro aus für ein Produkt, das
dann vielleicht nicht so geil ist, ist nicht cool.
Sollte nicht passieren.
Aber ist auch kein Weltuntergang.
Was kommt jetzt? Diesel? Dieselabgas?
Oder was kommt jetzt als Beispiel?
Wie den jüngsten Skandalen
um Activision Blizzard.
Woraus kam, dass in dieser Firma
systematisch über Jahre hinweg
Frauen und andere Minderheiten
aufs Übelste misshandelt wurden.
Merken wir jetzt.
Ich hab's ja am Anfang
das Thema auch so ein bisschen
ignoriert.
Bis ich dann vor
so zwei, drei Monaten auch ein bisschen mehr
zu dieser Thematik gelesen hab.
Es ist viel krasser, diese ganze
Geschichte, als man eigentlich so denkt und eigentlich
so mitbekommt. Wenn man sich da die Berichte
dazu durchliest. Wie gesagt, es gab Berichte
es gab
Artikel drüber
über Frauen, die
gesagt haben, ihre Führungskraft hat sie
und die wollten sogar vor Gericht gehen.
Ihre Führungskraft hat sie
vergewaltigt.
Oder auf Firmenfeiern quasi
abgefüllt, um sie danach zu vergewaltigen.
Das ist ultra krass, was da
abgelaufen ist. Das ist
wirklich absolut hardcore.
Und was hat Bobby unter anderem
gemacht oder wofür wurde unter anderem
gesorgt? Dass man sich außergerichtlich
geeinigt hat. Dass das
nicht irgendwie an die Öffentlichkeit
kommt. Und was wurde dann gemacht, wo man
normalerweise ja mal zumindest
irgendwelche
wie nennt man das so? Entscheidungsorgane
von Aufsichtsrat bis
Directors Board und was es da nicht alles gibt
informieren muss, haben die einfach mal nicht
informiert. Was da abgeht
ist richtig heftig.
Also
das habe ich am Anfang
selbst nicht so ganz gerafft.
Aber wenn man sich das mal ein bisschen
zu durchlegt, das ist wirklich krass, was da
abgegangen ist.
Die Firma kann sich nicht mal aufraffen
die allereinfachsten
PR Alibi
Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, um
irgendwie zu versuchen ihren Ruf zu reparieren.
Zum Beispiel bei Activision Blizzard.
Die haben danach gesagt, okay
wir ernennen jetzt bei Blizzard
Ach ja, das Beste.
Das Beste habe ich ja.
Zu dem Thema.
Es hat doch bei Blizzard angeblich
die, was war das?
Head of
Die eine, die sie da hatten
für
Diversity Fragen
und sonst was.
Die hat ja eine Mail
geschrieben, intern
an die Blizzard Mitarbeiter
Also für Harassment
und Diversity Fragen und sonst was.
Zumindest hatten sie da eine
und die hat eine Mail geschrieben, intern
an die Blizzard Mitarbeiter, wie stolz sie
eigentlich drauf ist, dass
sie bei so einer tollen
Firma arbeitet. Und wisst ihr, was dann
im Nachhinein rausgekommen ist?
Die Mail hat sie gar nicht selbst
geschrieben.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, wer diese Mail
in ihrem Namen geschrieben hat.
Der könnte es nur gewesen sein.
Und das hat er
sogar zugegeben.
Das hat er sogar zugegeben.
Alter.
Was ein armer
Clusterfuck, ey.
Ja gut.
Die Aktionen, die Blizzard da macht, sind ja
eh komplett
Tropfen auf den heißen
Stein. Das ist wie, dass
McCree in Overwatch umbenannt wird.
Das sind alles Aktionen,
die Blizzard macht, in der Hoffnung
sie stehen dann besser da.
Das ändert aber ja nicht die interne
so
Gesinnung
der
oder das
interne
den internen Antrieb
der Leute, die dort in Führungspositionen
sind, wenn McCree jetzt umbenannt
wird. Das ändert nicht die Kultur
in der Firma, wenn McCree jetzt nicht mal
McCree heißt. Das sind sicherlich
Sachen, die man machen kann. Wo man auch
sagen kann, ja das ist gerechtfertigt, okay.
Aber das ändert ja nichts
an der eigentlichen Problematik.
Das sind einfach nur Versuche von
Blizzard, das jetzt irgendwie mit
billigen Maßnahmen da rauszukommen.
McCree wurde umbenannt.
Ja, weil McCree
nach einem ehemaligen Mitarbeiter
glaube ich, bin mir da
nicht hundertprozentig sicher, ob ich das richtig erzähle,
nach einem ehemaligen Mitarbeiter
mitbenannt war, der in diesem ganzen Skandal
mit verstrickt ist.
Natürlich kann man McCree umbenennen.
Aber das ändert nicht
die Kultur in dieser Firma.
Das sorgt einfach nur dafür, dass man sagen kann,
hey Presse, guckt mal hier,
wir machen da was. Uns ist das
jetzt super wichtig, dass das hier bei uns
alles super läuft. Wenn es euch
super wichtig wäre, das erste, was ihr hättet machen müssen,
ist Bobby rausschmeißen und wahrscheinlich
90 Prozent der anderen Führungsriege.
Aber das geht ja nicht.
Weil stonks.
Ein Führungsduo aus einem
Mann und einer Frau, um
irgendwie zu zeigen, Leute, ab
jetzt wollen wir hier einen Kurs für mehr
Gleichberechtigung fahren. Das ist einfach nur was
vorgeschoben. Und nur ein paar
Monate später kam raus, die Firma
hat sich aktiv geweigert,
der Frau, Jen O'Neill,
das gleiche Gehalt für den gleichen
Job zu zahlen, wie dem Mann,
Mike Ibarra. Obwohl beide,
auch der Mann, das
mehrfach gefordert haben.
Und das zeigt doch,
diese Firma ist nicht mal bereit,
die allersimpelsten Maßnahmen
zu ergreifen, um irgendwie zumindest
so auszusehen, als würden sie
sich drum scheren um diesen Skandal.
Dafür haben sie doch jetzt
McCree umbenannt, Mensch.
Muss doch aber auch mal gut sein.
McCree umbenannt und
fertig.
Es ist einfach komplett egal.
Activision Blizzard hat alles Geld der Welt.
Die können mir doch nie im Leben sagen, dass es
ein großes Problem für sie gewesen
wäre, den beiden Blizzard
Chefs, also auch einem der
wichtigsten Posten in der ganzen Firma,
das gleiche Gehalt
zu zahlen.
Oh, da ist er.
Wie absurd diese Entscheidung ist.
Und ich finde,
wenn man all diese Dinge zusammennimmt,
die verschiedensten kaputten Releases
über die letzten Jahre,
von Anthem bis Battlefield,
die ganzen Skandale, wo wirklich
man immer wieder den Eindruck hat,
es werden eigentlich nur so mäßig
öffentlichkeitswirksame Alibi-Maßnahmen
ergriffen, statt wirklich grundlegend
was zu ändern. Das zeigt für mich halt,
es gibt ein großes Kontingent
bei den Entscheidungsträgern in der Gaming-Branche.
Und wie gesagt, das ist nicht der kleine
Entwickler an der Front.
Das sage ich ja auch öfters dabei,
wenn ich mich über solche Sachen aufrege,
da sage ich ja öfters dabei, hey, ich weiß,
dass die meisten Entwickler dafür nichts können.
Ich denke, das muss man auch der Fairness halber
dabei sagen, weil ich habe eben gerade
vor zehn Minuten schon mal gesagt,
die sind damit ja auch nicht glücklich.
Niemand wird gerne geflamed für ein Spiel,
wo er trotzdem eineinhalb, zwei Jahre hart
für gearbeitet hat und
was aus Gründen scheiße geworden ist,
wo der normale Entwickler
oder Level-Designer oder
Artist
absolut keinerlei Einfluss
drauf hat.
...deutlich weiter oben, die entschieden
haben, es ist doch eigentlich auch gar nicht
so wichtig, ob sich da ein paar Leute im Internet
aufregen. Das ist doch für
unsere Geschäftsergebnisse letztlich
egal. Die Frage ist...
Naja, VLOGSIG, ich denke, gerade wenn man
sich mal den Fall anguckt
von Battlefield 2042,
ich glaube, man kann
das gar nicht so sehr 100%
dem einen oder 100% dem anderen
zuschustern. Ich denke mal,
bei einem Fall von Battlefield 2042
sind es zwei maßgebliche Sachen. DICE
hat keinen Plan mehr, was sie machen.
Unabhängig von dieser Corona
Homeoffice-Geschichte oder so, die sicherlich auch
Probleme gemacht hat. Nexi, danke für den Sub.
DICE
hat es verkackt. Okay, das ist
Punkt Nummer eins.
EA hat es aber
insoweit verkackt, dass man eben
gesagt hat, okay, ähm,
jetzt ist es auch egal, wir müssen das
zum Weihnachtsgeschäft 2021 raushauen.
Also, dass quasi am Ende die
Entscheidung gefällt wurde, oder was heißt
am Ende? Ja, vorher.
Die Entscheidung gefällt
wurde, hier ist Deadline.
Also, die haben damit
bestimmt nicht dazu beigetragen. Es waren zwei Sachen.
DICE hat sicherlich mit verkackt,
weil das Spiel hat
ja in Ansätzen
schon
designtechnisch so große Probleme,
das kannst du nicht alles auf EA und
äh, mangelnde
Zeit schieben. Da sind so ganz
grundlegende Entscheidungen dabei.
Äh, da muss ich auch mal den
Aufbau der Maps angucken und sowas.
Aber dass es dann
wirklich released werden musste in diesem
Zustand, das ist wiederum die EA-Geschichte.
RolloW,
äh, oder
RolloWL, danke für den
Sub. Stimmt
das? Ist es wirklich eine schlaue
Strategie? Und es gibt, glaube ich, ein paar
Dinge, die tatsächlich dafür sprechen. Es ist so.
Und
der erste und wahrscheinlich auch wichtigste in der
Kalkulation ist,
weniger Leute kriegen diese Skandale
überhaupt mit, als wir denken.
Ja, da hat er
voll und ganz recht. Die 0815
Casual Mobile Gamer, die juckt das
nicht, die interessiert das nicht, die kriegen davon auch nichts mit.
Ja, und
äh, die Reddit
Empörten und Twitter Empörten
und sonst was, das ist halt nun mal die Minderheit.
Vielleicht die Gaming-Branche
verfolgen. Wenn ihr dieses Video
schaut, dann seid
ihr Teil der Zielgruppe, für die Gaming
interessant, die sich intensiv genug mit
Gaming beschäftigen,
dass ihr euch regelmäßig YouTube
Videos, Meinungsvideos dazu
anschaut. Das macht euch ja schon
zu Ausnahmepublikum, verglichen
mit der breiteren Gaming-Masse. Hört ihr's, Leute?
Wir sind massive big brain.
Wenn's gut läuft, nimm mal an,
werden's so 200.000 Leute
sehen. Und statistisch
gesehen, gucken sich diese
Leute im Schnitt die Hälfte des Videos
an. Die Konsolen-Versionen
von, also die schlechten Konsolen-Versionen
von Cyberpunk. Ähm, ja,
Baumhaus-Panzer, das kann durchaus passieren,
dass es langfristig keine gute Idee
ist. Aber es war bei der
Bahn, so jetzt mal ein Beispiel
außerhalb der Gaming-Branche zu nehmen,
es war bei der Bahn auch abzusehen,
dass es langfristig keine gute
Strategie ist, Strecken abzubauen.
Obwohl man
eigentlich mehr gebraucht hätte. Man hat es
aber für kurzfristige Stonks, Geld und
Gewinn trotzdem gemacht.
So kann das hier genauso laufen.
Für PS4 und Xbox One
haben sich im ersten
Monat über 7 Millionen
Mal verkauft.
Da ist es doch tatsächlich irgendwo
sogar nachvollziehbar, wenn ein Entscheidungsträger irgendwo
sagt, wenn sich ein paar YouTuber drüber
aufregen, wie viele
Leute kriegen das ernsthaft mit
versus wie viele Leute
keine Ahnung haben. Vor allem, wer kriegt das ernsthaft
mit und zieht daraus, das sind ja
noch viel weniger, zieht daraus
ernsthaft Konsequenzen?
Es kriegen schon halt viele mit
und die, die es mitkriegen, ziehen da wahrscheinlich
auch nicht wirklich Konsequenzen draus.
Und dann werden halt solche Entscheidungen
getroffen. FIFA
zum Beispiel. Jährlich
irgendwelche Skandale. Ist es zu
Pay2Win? Ist Ultimate Team doof?
Ist die PC-Version schon wieder
eine peinliche Enttäuschung?
Aber es ist eine pure Gelddruckmaschine
für EA. Völlig egal, wie viele
Leute sich um meinen drüber auflegen.
Das ist mir auch absolut ein Ding,
es gibt kaum was, was für mich so unverständlich ist.
Wie FIFA-Spieler.
Ich kann also nicht
nachvollziehen, wie man jedes
Jahr quasi wieder bei Null
anfangen kann und weiter
quasi in irgendwelche Glücksspiel
Surprise Mechanics
investiert.
Das kann doch eigentlich nur damit erklärt
werden, dass es irgendwelche Glückshormone
ausschüttet, wenn man
goldene Packages zieht, oder?
Was anderes kann es doch eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Was anderes kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen. Das ist mir komplett
unbegreiflich.
Weil es ein viel größeres Publikum
gibt. Ich kritisiere dieses Publikum gar nicht.
Ich sage ja gar nicht, jeder Gamer
sollte sich täglich YouTube-Videos über
all die Skandale der Branche anschauen.
Ich habe genauso Hobbies, die ich
vielmehr hobbymäßig verfolge.
Ich gucke mir auch nicht täglich YouTube-Videos zu
Netflix-Serien und Kinofilmen
an, weil das für mich mehr ein
Hobby ist, das ich so nebenbei habe.
Ich habe keine Ahnung über
die verschiedensten Produktionsbedingungen
bei jeder Netflix-Serie, die ich schaue,
zum Beispiel. Weil das wiederum für mich was ist,
wo ich sage, da habe ich
die Zeit, mich mit allen Hobbys, die ich habe,
so intensiv zu beschäftigen. Und genauso ist
das halt beim Gaming. Es gibt sehr viele Leute,
die diese ganzen Skandale gar
nicht mitkriegen. Und selbst von denen, die sie
mitkriegen, sei nur mehr ehrlich,
GTA 6
wird sich verkaufen wie geschnitten
Brot, egal wie viele Leute jetzt
sagen, wow, diese
Neuauflagen von den alten GTAs waren
aber echt eine Katastrophe. Garantiert.
Und jedes Mal, wisst ihr,
was ich auch witzig finde? Jedes Mal
wird dann von einem Release des Spiels gesagt,
so nach dem Motto, jetzt hat der Hersteller
endlich verstanden, was die Fans wollen.
Ah, doch nicht. Aber jetzt hat der
Hersteller endlich verstanden, was die Fans wollen.
Ah, wieder doch nicht. Aber dieses
Mal, dieses Mal hat der Hersteller
wirklich verstanden, was die Fans wirklich
wollen. Das ist ja auch ein Phänomen,
was man an allen Ecken und Enden beobachten
kann.
Letztlich egal. Das wird
nicht so viele Leute davon abbringen, sich das nächste
GTA zu kaufen. Nö, das wird sich verkaufen wie Sau.
Weil sie halt GTA-Fans sind, weil sie Bock drauf
haben, weil ihnen diese Neuauflagen
nicht so wichtig sind. Eine Runde Copium, genau.
Und ich sag auch gar nicht, dass man sich immer
um alles so scheren muss. Ich versuch hier nur, also
ich glaube, es gibt eben ein sehr
großes Publikum, das da einfach
sagen wird,
ist doch jetzt auch gar nicht so wichtig. Ja.
Das ist so. Das bin ich
nicht. Das ist ein Video von der GameStar,
was wir uns hier angucken.
Es gibt auch Leute, die
aktiv mir zum Beispiel
als Feedback geben, Junge, reg dich doch nicht
so auf. Ja, das hab ich
lustigerweise unter meinen Videos
auch. Und ja, ich kann das
sogar verstehen. Es gibt Leute, die sagen,
Max, guck mal,
du bist jetzt 37, was
regst du dich dann über irgendwie ein schlechtes
GameRelease auf? Und da muss
ich sagen,
eigentlich haben die Leute recht.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, es ist halt nun mal
ein Thema, was mich interessiert.
Und weil es ein Thema ist, was mich interessiert und auch
irgendwie so ein bisschen emotional mitnimmt,
ist das auch was, worüber ich mich eben auch
rege. Du kannst immer,
du kannst zu allem irgendwie sagen,
was nicht essentiell fürs Überleben ist,
ach, was regst du dich da drüber so auf?
Isst doch nicht so wild.
Ja.
Aber ich mein, wir vegetieren halt nun mal
nicht nur vor uns hin. Wir interessieren uns für andere
Sachen als für, äh,
wie krieg ich genug Essen und wo kann ich im Warmen
schlafen. Die Probleme haben wir ja glücklicherweise nicht mehr.
Zum Glück haben wir die hier nicht.
Und das halt,
das ist das erste Thema, wofür ich mich interessier.
Aber das hab ich unter meinen Videos auch.
Ich hab versucht, in meiner Berichterstattung
zu Diablo 2,
wo ich konnte,
auch auf die aktuellen Bedingungen bei
Blizzard hinzuweisen. Es gab
einerseits Leute, die gesagt haben, finde ich gut, dass du das machst,
da sollte man drüber reden. Ich hab aber auch
jedes Mal Kommentare bekommen, die gesagt haben,
jetzt kommt der schon wieder damit
an, wir wissen's doch inzwischen, halt
doch mal die Klappe, ich will doch nicht jedes Mal
daran erinnert werden, ich will doch einfach nur das Spiel
genießen und zocken. Das gibt's
genauso. Und auf solche Leute
setzen, glaub ich, diese großen Firmen,
wenn sie sagen, wenn wir's einfach
machen und totschweigen
und vielleicht
geht's ja auch gut für uns.
Klappt ja oft genug.
Ich glaub aber auch,
ganz persönlich,
es ist vielleicht ganz
langfristig gedacht, auch nicht
ganz zu Ende gedacht,
diese Strategie, weil man sieht...
Auf die Idee ist ja der Chat eben auch schon gekommen,
dass das langfristig nicht unbedingt
funktionieren muss.
Schon auch, wie es sich negativ
auf verschiedenste Entwickler auswirkt,
die diese Entscheidung getroffen haben.
Wenn sie Spiele
in einem offensichtlich kaputten Zustand
releasen, dann
erschwert das zumindest einen wichtigen Aspekt
der Spieleentwicklung, nämlich
die engagierten Fans
weiter zu monetarisieren.
Das stimmt. Guckt euch Battlefield an.
Weil dafür
brauchst du schon
eine Kernzielgruppe von
irgendwelchen Fans,
die bei der Stange bleiben,
die das Spiel weiter spielen.
Du brauchst...
Wer ist das, die letztendlich
die Spiele zu dem gemacht haben,
was sie heute sind?
Und wer ist das,
wer die Spiele langfristig spielen wird?
Das wird eine Gruppe aus Hardcore-Fans sein.
Deswegen sag ich ja auch,
du brauchst in Spielen,
sagen wir mal in irgendwelchen MMOs
oder sowas,
Content, der sich eben an
absolute
High-End-Leute richtet.
Content, den normale
0815-Casual-Gamer nie spielen werden.
Erstens, dass du was hast,
worauf du hinarbeiten kannst,
aber auch, dass du deine Hardcore-Fanbase,
die ein 15-Jahres-Abo
ohne Unterbrechung laufen lassen haben,
dass du die letztendlich
irgendwie zufriedenstellst.
Weil in schweren Zeiten sind das auch die,
die letztendlich dein Game am Leben halten.
Das beim Beispiel gilt für Multiplayer-Games.
Ich denke mal, das ist bei Singleplayer-Games
gar nicht so viel unterschiedlich.
Du hast da auch
bei manchen Spiele-Serien jetzt halt so
die Hardcore-Fanbase.
Guckt euch Dark Souls an,
hat auch sehr viele Fans.
Und sicherlich auch fannigere Fans
als andere.
Gibt da super viele Big-Brain-Leute,
die heute noch irgendwelche
Dark Souls-Videos machen,
obwohl das Spiel auch schon eigentlich
uralt ist, jetzt mal bis auf das Remake.
Irgendwelche Dark Souls-Videos machen so nach dem Motto
so sieht die Spawn-Animation
von Gegner XY von hinten aus
und sowas in der Richtung.
Und das gucken sich teilweise 150.000 Leute an.
Also,
das sind Leute, die die Games
langfristig am Leben halten.
Wir sehen das zum Beispiel bei Marvel's Avengers.
Die hatten einen riesigen Plan
für 10 Jahre Service-Game,
der offensichtlich jetzt nicht wirklich
aufzugehen scheint,
weil man nicht genügend
Fans binden konnte.
Man sieht es auch zum Beispiel bei Cyberpunk,
dass wenn Cyberpunk
in der gleichen Geschwindigkeit
DLCs erhalten hätte
wie The Witcher 3,
dann wäre da schon eine Erweiterung wie Blood & Wine
in den Startlöchern.
Eines der besten,
also nicht nur die beste Witcher-Erweiterung,
selbst wenn man nur Blood & Wine für sich nimmt,
finde ich das eines der besten Rollenspiele,
die es gibt.
Eines der besten Addons,
das ich je für ein Spiel gespielt habe.
Deswegen gucke ich wahrscheinlich Maurice gerne,
der sieht viele Sachen.
Wahrscheinlich gucke ich mir deswegen
gerne an, weil er viele Sachen so sieht,
wie ich sie auch sehe.
An dem Punkt, wo jetzt Cyberpunk ist,
war The Witcher 3 schon so weit,
dass es ein Addon wie Blood & Wine
erhalten konnte.
Cyberpunk ist immer noch damit beschäftigt,
Probleme vom Release zu fixen.
Und musste alle DLCs verschieben,
was ja auch
sich auf die Firmeneinnahme
natürlich niederschlägt.
Bugfix-Patches bringen kein Geld.
Also ein wenig schaden sich Firmen
schon damit.
Und man sieht es auch,
dass verschiedenste Firmen,
die verschiedenste Skandale in den letzten Jahren hatten,
doch auch
in ihrem Aktienkurs drunter gelitten haben.
Maurice sollte mal ein Video machen
zu seinem Fitnessprogramm.
Der Typ hat so krass abgenommen.
Müsst ihr euch mal die Videos angucken
vor drei Jahren oder so.
Da war er so ungefähr so ein bisschen
Pepo Fett in meine Richtung.
Und heute hat er hier die halbe
Boss-Transformation hinter sich.
Auch in ihrem Aktienkurs drunter gelitten haben.
CD Projekt, Ubisoft
und Activision Blizzard.
Bei allen dreien ist der Aktienkurs
in den letzten zwölf Monaten
relativ kontinuierlich
gefallen oder stagniert.
Statt hochzugehen.
Und vielleicht zeigt
das schon, dass man
auch aus schlauer Firmensicht
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr darauf achten sollte,
was man dem Kunden
zumutet.
Ja, aber, wie gesagt,
ist die Frage, was überwiegt.
Man hat bei der Bahn auch Strecken
abgebaut, obwohl man wusste, dass das
langfristig nicht sinnvoll ist.
Wenn man nur auf kurzfristiges
Quartal, wenn man sich
von Quartalsergebnis zu
Quartalsergebnis hangelt,
dann interessieren so langfristige
Sachen nicht. Dann interessieren so
langfristige Sachen erst,
wenn es spürbar nach unten geht
und dann stellt man wahrscheinlich
einen neuen Geschäftsführer ein oder so,
der einem dann das Blaue vom Himmel runter
verspricht, wie sehr er den Laden rumreißen wird.
Und das erste, was dann passiert, und das ist immer
das Bittere daran ist, dass erstmal
40% der Entwickler entlassen wurden,
die nichts anderes gemacht haben,
als ihre komplette Energie
die letzten Jahre in das Produkt zu stecken.
Da trifft es immer erstmal komplett die Falschen.
Und wie transparent man damit ist
und ob man nicht vielleicht eher besser beraten wäre,
dann mal die Aktionäre zu überzeugen,
Leute, wir müssen
das Spiel nochmal um ein Jahr verschieben.
Und ihr wisst sowieso, liebe Aktionäre,
wenn wir Cyberpunk ein Jahr später rausbringen,
mit einer funktionierenden Last-Gen-Konsolen-Version,
wird es sich ja trotzdem
super verkaufen.
Und ich würde hoffen,
dass diese Lektion vielleicht langfristig
mal gelernt wird, aber,
wenn man sich die Gaming-Branche als Ganzes anschaut,
glaube ich,
ist es nicht so.
Ich habe den Eindruck,
viele Firmen, viele Entscheidungsträger
haben für sich beschlossen,
wir probieren jetzt erstmal diesen Kurs
im Zweifelsfall
lieber releasen
und lieber totschweigen
und hinterher die Probleme lösen,
als zu versuchen, sie im Vorfeld zu vermeiden.
Und ich glaube deswegen,
dass wir uns darauf einstellen müssen,
dass uns Sachen
wie die Konsolen-Version von Cyberpunk,
wie die Releases von Battlefield
Trilogy und Anthem
Das ist sicherlich nicht
die Ausnahme.
Fallout 76, was auch immer es noch alles gab,
das ist schon in die Hose gegangen, auch vor Corona
und wird auch weiterhin in die Hose gehen.
Das will ich auch nochmal ganz klar sagen,
ich will diese Skandale nicht gleichstellen
in diesem Video, also kaputte Spiele
und Misshandlung von
Mitarbeitern.
Ja, das muss man immer besonders ausführlich betonen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich hätte das
Maurice so auch nie unterstellt, aber es sind Leute
die sich nicht krass getriggert im Zweifelsfall,
muss man immer nochmal Disclaimer anbringen.
Das sind Skandalen auf unterschiedlichem Niveau,
was eben nur für mich
eine gewisse Parallelaufweise ist.
Ich wäre gar nicht auf die Idee gekommen,
dass man sich daran stören könnte.
Eine gewisse Gleichgültigkeit der Firmenchefs
über die Empörung darüber.
Also abseits von
PR-Statements.
Aber auch diese deutlich schlimmeren Dinge
glaube ich, dass wir uns darauf einstellen müssen.
Da wird noch mehr ans Licht kommen.
Mit Sicherheit.
Guckt mal, was bei Ubisoft abgeht.
Nicht immer zumindest
ernsthafte Bestrebungen folgen
da wirklich
Besserung zu tun.
Und deswegen glaube ich,
das Spielejahr 2022
wird nochmal eher schlimmer als besser werden.
Wie seht ihr das?
Wie fandet ihr das Jahr 2021?
Ich würde da im Großen und Ganzen schon zustimmen.
Einen Wendepunkt?
Ups.
Ja, da wollte ich jetzt gar nicht draufklicken, aber okay.
Heute waren ja auch einige Leute
von meinem Video getriggert.
Weil ich
am Anfang einen
christlichen Systemadministrator
Job gezeigt habe.
Da haben auch welche gesagt hier,
ich finde das nicht gut,
dass du dich so lustig machst über
christliche Sachen.
Was ja auch ihr Recht ist.
Können sich ja darüber beschweren.
Was aber nicht heißt, dass ich was anderes sage im Video.
Brage.
Leute, schon spät.
Schon spät.
Ich sehe es gerade.
Uma, Bettke.
Müde.
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns
wahrscheinlich direkt morgen wieder,
denke ich mal.
Dann machen wir vielleicht ein bisschen Technik-Krams.
Also bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.